हेलो
एवरीवन एंड वेरी गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल एंड
फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल हैप्पी न्यू ईयर टू
ऑल नए साल की बहुत-बहुत बधाई हो आप सभी को
मुबारकबाद हो तो सबसे पहले मुझे यह बताइए
कि सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है या
नहीं दे रही यह भी बता दीजिए साथ के साथ
ओके थैंक यू थैंक
यू हैप्पी न्यू ईयर टू
ऑल ओके थोड़ा सा वेट करते हैं दो मिनट का
तो आज नया साल है न्यू ईयर है
224 बाय बाय एंड 2025 इज वेलकम और इस
वेलकम पर
हम ने भी क्या सोचा कि डे फोनिक्स अकेडमी
की तरफ से भी एक शानदार वेलकम करते हैं एक
शानदार एक धमाकेदार टॉपिक जिसका नाम है
सिस्टम हैकिंग उसको हम स्टार्ट करने वाले
हैं नेक्स्ट वन मंथ के लिए या वन एंड हाफ
मंथ के लिए हम इसी टॉपिक में रहेंगे फुल
प्रैक्टिकल टॉपिक रहेगा इसमें भर भर के
टेक्निक्स होंगे टूल्स होंगे और आपके पास
टैक्टिक्स
होंगी तो आज की क्लास
ओनली जस्ट जो आपका बेसिक इंफॉर्मेशन जो
आपकी जरूरत है आपको समझने की कि सिस्टम
हैकिंग के अंदर होता क्या-क्या है
क्या-क्या हम करने वाले हैं बस्ट उसका
इंट्रोडक्शन रहेगा आज की क्लास में
क्योंकि आर टोटल 30 टू 35 स्लाइड्स आर
देयर जहां पर आपको मैं सब कुछ बताऊंगा कि
हम एक्चुअल में सिस्टम हैकिंग के अंदर
क्या-क्या करने वाले हैं तो समझ जाना
स्लाइड के हिसाब से कि हम क्या-क्या होने
वाला है सिस्टम हैकिंग के अंदर उसके बाद
नेक्स्ट क्लास से हम फर्स्ट लैब के साथ
स्टार्ट करेंगे तो तब तक के
लिए अगर आपने ट्राई हैक मी पे अकाउंट नहीं
क्रिएट किया है तो कर लीजिए जहां तक है
फ्री लैब्स रहेंगी प्रीमियम अकाउंट की
जरूरत नहीं है हैक द बॉक्स है तो वहां पर
भी अकाउंट कर लीजिए क्रिएट कर
लीजिए ओके तो यह आपकी प्री रिक्विजिट है
यह आपकी रिक्वायरमेंट है तो आज के सेशन को
प्लीज ड्रॉप मत करना कि मैं आपको स्लाइड
के थ्रू ओनली की फंडामेंटल्स बता रहा तो
आपको पता होगा मुझे पता आपको पता होगा बट
बहुत सारी ऐसी चीजें होंगी शायद आपको ना
पता हो या आप भूल गए होंगे आपको याद दिला
रहा हूं क्योंकि वो इसी का पार्ट होती है
ये एक अप्रोच है इसी अप्रोच में हम
परफॉर्म करेंगे अब जितने भी हमारे
प्रैक्टिकल टास्क रहेंगे ओके तो यहां पर
जो चीज आपको स्लाइड के थ्रू बताई जाएगी या
शो रिप्रेजेंट की जाएगी वह सिर्फ आपका
हिंट है कि क्या-क्या होने वाला है लेकिन
अब क्लास के बीच में हम कंटीन्यूअसली
सिस्टम हैकिंग के अंदर पहले लिनक्स हैकिंग
सीखेंगे देन उसके बाद विंडोज हैकिंग
सीखेंगे इन दोनों हैकिंग को सीखेंगे वन
बाय वन बट वह सारी टोटली टोटली आपके
सीटीएफ बेस्ड रहेंगी अब सीटीएफ में जो
टेक्निक्स जो ट्रिक्स आपको रिक्वायर्ड
एक्सप्लेन करने की आई विल एक्सप्लेन जो
टूल रिक्वायर्ड है आई विल
एक्सप्लेन जो बेसिक उसका फंडामेंटल
कांसेप्ट आपको रिक्वायर्ड है आई विल
एक्सप्लेन सारी चीजें मैं आपको एक्सप्लेन
करूंगा यह आप लोगों को चिंता करने की
जरूरत नहीं है और विंडोज के केस में आपको
पहले ही एक हिंट प्रोवाइड कर देता हूं कि
विंडोज हैकिंग स्टार्ट करने से पहले हम
उसके फंडामेंटल्स जानेंगे अब वो फंडामेंटल
शायद किसी ने नहीं पढ़ाए होंगे या आपने
पढ़े होंगे तो व इस ऑर्गेनाइज वे में नहीं
होंगे जो आपको जरूरत है बिफोर स्टार्टिंग
इंडोज हैकिंग जैसे फंडामेंटल्स में होता
है कि उसका बूटिंग प्रोसेस सीक्वेंस कैसे
काम करता है रजिस्टर्स कैसे काम करते क्या
होते हैं सर्विसेस क्या होती हैं या
एप्लीकेशंस कैसे काम करती है उसका इंटरनल
इंटरनेट नेटवर्क कैसे काम करता है यह सारी
चीजें जो आपकी काफी हेल्पफुल होती है
शेड्यूल टास्क क्या होते हैं तो ये सारी
चीजें आपके लिए काफी हेल्पफुल होगी जब आप
विंडोज हैकिंग करते हो अगर आपको इनकी
फंडामेंटल नॉलेज नहीं होगी तब भी आपके लिए
प्रोग्रामेटिक रहता है एज ए बिगनर तो ये
सारी चीजें हम परफॉर्म करने वाले हैं तब
तक के लिए ओके दे 52 स्टूडेंट्स तो अभी
स्टार्ट करेंगे जस्ट गिव अवे वन मिनट
थोड़ा सा और वेट करते हैं शायद
आप मैक्सिमम स्टूडेंट आने चाहिए आज तो
आजकल तो आपको एज ए फ्रेशर आनी
चाहिए क्योंकि अभी जो कंपनिया है शुभम जो
कंपनी है वह एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी पर ज्यादा
फोकस कर रही है मतलब एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी को
ज्यादा यूज कर रही है अपने वर्किंग
एनवायरमेंट में तो इसलिए पेन टेस्टर को
अगर एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी पन टेस्टिंग करनी
आती तो शायद उसके लिए प्रॉब्लमैटिक
आपको एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी पन टेस्टिंग आनी
चाहिए आपको एड पन टेस्टिंग आनी चाहिए
लिनक्स हैकिंग लिनक्स पन टेस्टिंग वेब
एप्लीकेशन पेन टेस्टिंग विंडोज पेन
टेस्टिंग चाहे वह होस्ट बेस अटैक्स हो
चाहे आपके नेटवर्क बेस अटैक्स हो जब वेब
बेस अटैक्स हो सारी की सारी चीजें आपको
पता होनी चाहिए
हां विदाउट पेन ड्राइव आपको पेन ड्राइव
बूटेबल बनानी पड़ेगी एक बार आपको जब आप
सिस्टम इंस्टॉल करना होगा ड्यूल बूटिंग के
दौरान देन ही आप क्या कर सकते हो दूसरा
तरीका क्या होता है एनएफएस नेटवर्क फाइल
शेयर के थ्रू नेटवर्क के थ्रू भी आप कर
सकते हो बट वह क्या है आपके डोमेन पीसी के
लिए परफेक्ट एग्जांपल जहां पर क्या है
विंडो सर्वर अवेलेबल होते हैं एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी सर्वर्स अवेलेबल होते हैं जहां
आप नेटवर्क के थ्रू भी आप डल बूट कर सकते
हैं बट वह आप अपने लैपटॉप के साथ नहीं कर
पाओगे
निखिल यह कोर्स आपके सीच से कई ज्यादा
गुना है ज्यादा है सीच इ लिटिल चाइल्ड इन
फ्रंट ऑफ दिस
कोर्स ऑलरेडी पहले क्लास का नोट्स पप पर
अपलोड हो चुका
है क्विक टेक्नो सर्विस आपका जवाब यह है
कि जब आप किसी कंपनी में एज ए पेन टेस्टर
काम करोगे तो आपको पेन टेस्टिंग के लिए
उनके नेटवर्क में भी आपको एक्सेस दिया
जाता है ओके तो आप जब एज ए पेंटेस्टर जॉब
करते हो तो कोई भी कंपनी अपने नेटवर्क पर
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग क्यों करवाती है ताकि
वह वनटी असेसमेंट कर पाए वह जो शोक
एनालिस्ट है अच्छे से अपने डिफेंस कर पाए
चीजों
को सीटी के नाम तो आप लोगों को साथ के साथ
पता चलेंगे कौन-कौन से सीटीएफ से रहेंगे
अगर आप लोगों ने किए हुए हैं तो वेरी वेल
मेरा मेरा करवाने का मतलब यह है ताकि आप
लोग ट्रिक्स टेक्निक्स और उससे रिलेटेड
आपका बेसिक फंडामेंटल क्लियर हो जाए ओके
क्लास को स्टार्ट करते हैं तो ज्यादा टाइम
वेस्ट नहीं करेंगे क्योंकि स्लाइड्स
ज्यादा है टॉपिक्स ज्यादा है तो जहां पर
मुझे एक्सप्लेन करने की रिक्वायरमेंट वहां
पर एक्सप्लेन करूंगा जहां पर रिक्वायरमेंट
नहीं है मैं वहां पर एक्सप्लेन नहीं
करूंगा ओके आपको स्लाइड एप्स प मिल जाएंगी
जो हमारी पप है डे फोनिक्स एप्लीकेशन है
या आपको जो 0 वाला जो आपने सब्सक्रिप्शन
लिया था उसमें आपको सार स्लाइड मिल जाएंगी
वहां से आप क्या कर सकते हो पढ़ सकते
हो
चलो पिछली स्लाइड अखिलेश हो चुकी है अगर
आप लोग टेक्निकल नेविगेटर सर नितेश सर सर
अगर आप मेरी लाइव क्लास में हो अभी तो
प्लीज या टीम मेंबर कोई भी लाइव क्लास में
है तो प्लीज रिप्लाई कीजिए उनको क्योंकि
मैं अपडेट करवा चुका
हूं अभी डाउनलोड का ऑप्शन तो नहीं होगा
आपको शायद क्योंकि मैं अपनी स्लाइड के साथ
कंप्रोमाइज नहीं कर सकता ना तो ओके तो आज
स्टार्ट करते हैं हम सिस्टम हैकिंग सेक्शन
फोर अभी हम बोल सकते हैं ब्रेकिंग द
सिस्टम एथिकल हैकिंग टेक्निक्स ऑन विंडोज
एंड
ओके तो आज से नया टॉपिक स्टार्ट कर रहे
हैं तो सबसे पहले वेलकम टू वर्ल्ड ऑफ
सिस्टम हैकिंग मतलब होता क्या तो इमेजिन
यू हैव द पावर टू अनकवर हिडन वलने बिटीज
इन एनी कंप्यूटर सिस्टम बी इट इज अ विंडोज
वर्क स्टेशन और ए लिनक्स सर्वर तो नाउ
थिंक अबाउट यूजिंग दिस सुपर पा पावर टू
प्रोटेक्ट बिजनेस सिक्योर डाटा एंड आउट
स्मार्ट साइबर क्रिमिनल्स
बेसिकली क्या है कि आप सोचिए कि आपके पास
एक ऐसी सुपर पावर है या आपके पास एक ऐसी
नॉलेज है जो आप जो हिडन वल्नरेबल कीज होती
है कंप्यूटर सिस्टम के अंदर वो आप क्या कर
सकते हो अनकवर कर सकते हो फाइंड आउट कर
सकते हो और इस सुपर पावर को आप जो बोल
सकते हो आप किस पर्पस से यूज करते हो किसी
भी बिजनेस को प्रोटेक्ट करने के लिए अपने
डाटा को सिक्योर करने के लिए किसी
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के डाटा को सिक्योर करने के
लिए और साइबर क्रिमिनल को पकड़ने के लिए
तो दिस इज द आर्ट ऑफ सिस्टम हैकिंग इन
एथिकल हैकिंग
ओके जितना सुनने में अच्छा लग रहा है
एक्चुअल में उतना ही अच्छा है ओके तो
व्हाट इज सिस्टम
हैकिंग सिस्टम हैकिंग इज नॉट जस्ट अबाउट
ब्रेकिंग इनटू सिस्टम इट इज अबाउट
अंडरस्टैंडिंग देम डीप अनकवरिंग देर
सीक्रेट्स एश्योरिंग दे आर शील्ड अगेंस्ट
अटैकर्स ओके तो इट इज ए स्किल दैट ब्लैंड
क्यूरिसिटी
क्रिएटिविटी एंड टेक्निकल मास्टरी इफ यू
हैव एवर वंडर्स लाइक टू स्टेप इन टू द शूज
ऑफ ए साइबर सिक्योरिटी बैरियर दिस इज योर
चांस बेसिकली मेरा कहने का मतलब क्या है
कि कि सिस्टम को ब्रेक करना ही सिस्टम
हैकिंग नहीं है सिस्टम को डीप समझना उसके
सीक्रेट को अनकवर करना और अटैकर से सिस्टम
को बचाना यह सारी चीजें क्या है आपके
सिस्टम हैकिंग का पार्ट है जस्ट सिस्टम को
ब्रेक करना ही सिस्टम का पार्ट सिस्टम
हैकिंग का पार्ट नहीं है
ओके नाउ व्हाट इज सिस्टम हैकिंग सिस्टम
हैकिंग इज ए क्रिटिकल फेज इन एथिकल हैकिंग
दैट फोकस ऑन गेनिंग एंड मेंटे निंग
अनऑथराइज्ड एक्सेस टू कंप्यूटर सिस्टम ओके
इट इवॉल्व
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
एंड कॉन्फ़िगरेशन
एंड एक्सप्लोइटिंग देम टू डेमोंस्ट्रेट
पोटेंशियल सिक्योरिटी रिस्क बेसिकली जो
सिस्टम हैकिंग होता है एथिकल हैकिंग का
सबसे क्रिटिकल फेज होता है जिसके अंदर आप
क्या करते हो किसी भी सिस्टम के अंदर
एक्सेस गेन करते हो ऑलरेडी एजिस्ट वटी के
थ्रू उसके बाद सेशन को मेंटेन करते हो अन
ऑथराइज जहां पर आपको ऑथराइज नहीं होता बट
ये क्या कि जब आप ब्लैक ड कर रहे होते ओके
अब उन वनटी को आप क्या करते किसी भी
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम में फाइंड आउट कर हो या
किसी एप्लीकेशन के अंदर या किसी कॉन्फिन
फाइल के अंदर और उनको एक्सप्लोइट करके आप
उस पोटेंशियल सिक्योरिटी रिस्क को शॉक टीम
है जो या कंपनी की जो पन टेस्टिंग टीम है
या कंपनी आईटी टीम है उसको क्या करते हो
शो करते हो कि दिस इज द योर पोटेंशियल
सिक्योरिटी रिस्क टू योर कंपनी द प्राइमरी
गोल ऑफ सिस्टम हैकिंग इन एथिकल हैकिंग इज
टू असेस एंड स्ट्रेंथ द सिक्योरिटी पोचर
ऑफ ए सिस्टम वा एडरिंग टू एथिकल एंड लीगल
गाइडलाइंस ओके तो साइबर सिक्योरिटी
थ्रेट्स आर इवॉल्विंग एवरी सेकंड हर एक
सेकंड में एक नया साइबर थ्रेड क्रिएट हो
रहा है तो एवरी डे अटैकर्स आर फाइंडिंग
न्यू वेज टू ब्रेक इन टू सिस्टम्स एंड
लर्निंग सिस्टम हैकिंग इक्विप यू विद द
स्किल टू स्टे अहेड प्रोटेक्ट एसेट्स एंड
क्रिएट ए सेफर डिजिटल वर्ल्ड बेसिकली क्या
है कि साइबर सिक्योरिटी फील्ड में हर रोज
एक नया थ्रेड हर एक सेकंड में एक नया
थ्रेड क्या कर रहा है क्रिएट हो रहा है और
हर एक दिन अटैकर्स कोई ना कोई नया तरीका
फाइंड आउट कर रहा है सिस्टम को ब्रेक करने
का आप ये सारी स्किल आप सीख के क्या कर
सकते हो अटैकर से पहले अहेड एक स्टेप आगे
चल सकते हो अपने असेट असेट कौन से होते
हैं आपके वर्क स्टेशंस आपके लैपटॉप्स आपके
मोबाइल्स आपके पीसीज उन सबको क्या कर सकते
हो आप बचा सकते हो प्रोटेक्ट कर सकते हो
और जो डिजिटल वर्ल्ड है चाहे वो आपका
डिजिटल वर्ल्ड हो चाहे वो किसी भी
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन डिजिटल वर्क को आप उसको क्या
कर सकते हो एक सेफ्टी प्रोवाइड कर सकते हो
व्हेन एवर यू आर टेक ऑथर्स एंड ए बर्डिंग
हैकर और एन आईटी प्रोफेशनल दिस स्किल सेट
इज योर गिव वे टू ए थ्रिलिंग एंड
इंपैक्टफुल
कैरियर तो सिस्टम हैकिंग फॉलोज ए प्रोसाइज
मैथोलॉजी अप्रोच विदाउट दिस अप्रोच यू आर
लाइक ए सेलर नेविगेटिंग विदाउट ए मैप
लॉस्ट एंड एमले बेसिकली क्या है कि जो
सिस्टम हैकिंग होती है उसमें एक प्रेसा इज
एक मेथोड अप्रोच होती है अगर आप उसको फॉलो
नहीं करते हो तो आप उस नाविक की तरह हो जो
आप समुंदर में नाव लेकर चले तो गए हो
लेकिन ना तो आपके पास मैप है ना आपके पास
रास्ता है ना आपको जहां पर आप क्या है एम
लेस बस चले जा रहे हो लेकिन आपको पता नहीं
जाना क्या है और कैसे चलना है उसी की तरह
हो ना अभी बात करते हैं उन मेथोडोलोग्य
हो जब आपके पास इंफॉर्मेशन आ जाती है
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करते हो स्कैनिंग करते
हो और एन्यूमरेशन करते हो देन उसके बाद उस
इंफॉर्मेशन के आधार पर आप क्या करते हो
वल्नरेबल एनालिसिस करते हो आइडेंटिफिकेशन
सिस्टम के अंदर क्या करते हो एसिस्टिंग
वनबिल को फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश करते हो
या उसकी जो कमजोरियां है उनको फाइंड आउट
करने की कोशिश करते हो देन जब आपको एक बार
वनटी मिल जाती है उस वनटी को आप क्या करते
हो एक्सप्लोइट करते हो एक्सप्लोइट करने के
बाद आप क्या करते हो थर्ड स्टेप एक्सेस
गेन करते हो जो आपका फर्स्ट फुट होल्ड
होता है फुट होल्ड का मतलब आप फर्स्ट गेन
फर्स्ट एंट्री पॉइंट होता आप सिस्टम के
साथ क्या करते हो एक्सेस बना हो ओके चाहे
वो स्टैंडर्ड यूजर हो चाहे
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव यूजर हो जब फोर्थ स्टेप
की बात आती है देन उसके बाद आप क्या करते
हो प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन करते हो अब
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन हर एक केस में जरूरी
नहीं है उसी केस में जरूरी है जब आपको
अनप्रिविलेज्ड अकाउंट मिलता है या आपको जो
एक्सेस मिला है वह अनप्रिविलेज्ड है मतलब
आप एक स्टैंडर्ड यूजर हो और आपको अपने
टास्क परफॉर्म करने के लिए एक प्रिविलेज
अकाउंट चाहिए तो उस केस में आप क्या करते
हो प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन टेक्निक का यूज
करते हो नेक्स्ट जब आप एक बार प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन करते हो देन उसके बाद आपको अपने
सेशन को अपने इस अटैक को या अपने जो
एक्सेस लिया था उसको मेंटेन करना होता है
उसको मेंटेन करने के लिए भी आप बहुत सारे
टेक्निक्स का यूज करते हो बहुत सारे टूल्स
का यूज करते हो बैकडोर्स को इंस्टॉल करते
हो या यूजर अकाउंट क्रिएट करते हो अपने
एक्सेस को मेंटेन करने के लिए असिस्टेंट
बनाने के लिए टेक्निक्स इंक्लूडिंग
प्लांटिंग ट्रोजस मॉडिफाइड फाइल्स एंड
लेवरेजिंग शेड्यूल टास्क जब आप एक बार
एक्सेस मेंटेन कर लेते हो सिस्टम ज्यादा
से ज्यादा सिस्टम को आप एक्सप्लोइट कर
लेते हो आप कंप्लीट पेन टेस्टिंग कर लेते
हो देन आपका सिक्स स्टेप्स आता है कवरिंग
ट्रैक्स कवरिंग ट्रैक्स में क्या करते हो
आप लॉक क्लियर करते हो आपने जो भी सिस्टम
पे काम किया आपने जो भी उसके अंदर बैकडोर
इंस्टॉल किया जो भी आपने टूल इंस्टॉल किया
या जो जो काम किया जहां-जहां पर जो फाइल
आपने उस पर इंस्टॉल की है उस जब लास्ट में
आपका क्या काम होता है अपने सारे सबूत को
मिटाना अपने सारे ट्रैक्स को छोड़ना ताकि
आपको कोई डिटेक्ट ना कर पाए कि कोई हटकर
सिस्टम के अंदर एंटर भी हुआ था या नहीं
हुआ था तो आपको क्लियर लक करने पड़ते हैं
टेंपरेरी फाइल को डिलीट करना होता है ऑफर
स्केटिंग एक्टिविटीज टू अवॉइड डिटेक्शन
इंश्योर द हैकर्स प्रेजेंस रिमेंस
अननोटिसड तो आप सिस्टम हैकिंग के लिए इन
छह मेथड का यूज करते हो ओके यहां तक सभी
को क्लियर है प्लीज बताइए
बताइए बताइए दे 57 स्टूडेंट्स तो सभी के
सभी प्लीज बताइए यस या नो
ओके
नेक्स्ट अभी एक छोटा सा एक बोलते हैं ना
कि आपके लिए एक मोटिवेशन कुछ लाइने है तो
मैं आपको बता देता हूं मीनिंग खुद से समझ
लेना गेट रेडी टू डाइव इनटू ए वर्ल्ड वेयर
एवरी सिस्टम इज चैलेंज एवरी वनटी इज एन
अपॉर्चुनिटी और एवरी सक्सेस फील्स लाइक ए
विक्ट्री विद द स्ट्रक्चर्ड अप्रोच टू
सिस्टम हैकिंग यू विल गेन क्लेरिटी
कॉन्फिडेंस एंड क कंटेंस लाइक नेवर बिफोर
विदाउट इट यू रिस्क इनएफिशिएंसी एंड मिस्ड
अपॉर्चुनिटी
सो आर यू रेडी टू बिकम द अन अल्टीमेट
एथिकल हैकर्स एंड सिस्टम प्रोटेक्टर्स एंड
लेट्स गेट स्टार्टेड एवरीवन रेडी
ओके वेरी
गुड तो सबसे पहले हम बात करते हैं सिस्टम
हैकिंग के अंदर कुछ
इंपोर्टेंट कुछ टॉपिक्स होते हैं जिनके
बारे में बात करते हैं जो आपको नहीं पता
होगा सिस्टम या होस्ट बेस अटैक्स किसी को
पता कि सिस्टम और होस्ट बेस अटैक्स होते
क्या है किसी ने सुना इस टम को किसी ने भी
सुना है कि सिस्टम या होस्ट बेस अटैक्स
किनको बोलते हैं किसी को पता है एनी वन
अवेयर
बताइए सभी लोग अवेयर है कि सिस्टम और
होस्ट बेस अटैक्स होते क्या हैं
किसी को नहीं
पता नहीं नहीं
नहीं कोई भी बताने की कोशिश
करेगा हां कुछ लोग ट्राई कर रहे हैं
एग्जैक्ट बता नहीं पा
रहे ओके चलो मैं बता देता
हूं इंट्रोडक्शन टू सिस्टम एंड होस्ट बेस
अटैक्स बिफोर स्टार्टिंग एनी ऑफ द
एक्सप्लोइटेशन टेक्निक दैट वी कैन परफॉर्म
ऑन बोथ विंडोज एंड नक् लेट्स गेट एन
अंडरस्टैंडिंग ऑफ व्हाट सिस्टम और होस्ट
बेस अटैक्स आर एंड व्हाई दे आर सो
पोर्टेंट ओके
चलो व्हाट आर सिस्टम एंड होस्ट बेस
अटैक्स सिस्टम एंड होस्ट बेस अटैक्स आ
टाइप्स ऑफ साइबर अटैक्स एम एट ए स्पेसिफिक
कंप्यूटर सर्वर और डिवाइस ट इज रनिंग ए
पर्टिकुलर ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम लाइक विंडोज
नक् और मैक ओस या इनके
डिस्ट्रीब्यूशन द गोल ऑफ दज अटैक्स इज टू
फाइंड एंड एक्सप्लोइट वीकनेस
और वलने बिलिटी इन द सिस्टम और होस्ट सबको
समझ में आया या नहीं
आया सिस्टम या होस्ट बेस अटैक एक ऐसे
साइबर अटैक्स होते हैं जो किसी स्पेसिफिक
मशीन सर्वर या डिवाइस को टारगेट करते हैं
मशीन का मतलब मेरा यहां पर वर्क स्टेशन हो
सकते हैं आपके मोबाइल फोनस हो सकते हैं
आपके आईपैड हो सकते हैं आपके पर्सनल
कंप्यूटर हो सकते हैं या आपके लैपटॉप हो
सकते हैं यह अटैक्स उन सिस्टम पर फोकस
करते हैं जो
सिस्टम के अंदर मौजूद वीकनेसेस और वटी को
ढूंढकर
उनका फायदा
उठाना ओके यह इनका मेन गोल होता है ओके तो
सबको समझ में आया कि सिस्टम और होस्ट बेस
अटैक होता क्या भी
एवरीवन सबको समझ में
आया की डेफिनेशन समझ में आई कि अब कोई
आपसे पूछता है कि सिस्टम या होस्ट बेस
अटैक्स होते क्या हैं
एवरीवन
ओके तो नेटवर्क सर्विसेस आर नॉट द ओनली
अटैक वेक्टर्स दैट कैन बी टारगेटेड
ड्यूरिंग ए पेनेट्रेशन टेस्टिंग ओके
सिस्टम एंड होस्ट बेस अटैक्स यूजुअली कम
इन टू प्ले आफ्टर यू हैव गेन एक्सेस टू अ
टारगेट नेटवर्क वयर यू विल बी रिक्वायर्ड
टू एक्सप्लोइट सर्वर्स वर्क स्टेशंस और
एंप्लॉई लैपटॉप्स ऑन द इंटरनल नेटवर्क ओके
अगर जिसको अभी समझ में नहीं आया थोड़ा
बहुत तो अभी एग्जांपल में आपको समझ में
आएगा कि ओनली एक ही अटैक वेक्टर्स नहीं है
कि आप नेटवर्क सर्विसेस को अटैक करो और
एक्सप्लोइट करो नहीं सिस्टम और होस्ट बेस
अटैक्स भी आपके लिए उतने ही इंपॉर्टेंट है
जितने नेटवर्क बेस अटैक्स होते हैं आपके
ओके और मेनली इसका रोल स्टार्ट होता है
आपका जब आप एक बार मशीन को एक्सप्लोइट कर
लेते हो और आपको एक्सेस मिल जाता है
नेक्स्ट स्लाइड प चलते हैं इमेजिन यू ओन ए
हाउस योर हाउस हैज मल्टीपल एंट्री पॉइंट्स
डोर्स विंडोज एंड मे बी इवन ए गैरेज नाउ
लेट्स से यू फॉरगेट टू लॉक वन ऑफ द विंडोज
ए थप वकिंग बाय वकिंग बाय नोटिसेज दिस
वीकनेसेस एंड स्निक्स इन थ्रो दैट ओपन
विंडो टू स्टील योर वैल्यूएबल्स बेसिकली
इसका कहने का मतलब कि आपका खुद का घर है
उसमें मल्टीपल सेंट्री पॉइंट्स होते हैं
जैसे आपकी खिड़कियां दरवाजे आपके गैरेज और
जब आप घर से बाहर कहीं पर जा रहे थे आपने
गलती से एक खिड़की खुली छोड़ दी ओके अब
उसी खिड़की पर नजर पड़ गई चोर की अब चोर
ने क्या किया उस खिड़की के थ्रू क्या किया
घर में एंट्री ली और आपके जो वैल्युएबल सी
जो इंपोर्टेंट चीजें थी वो चुरा ली सेम
चीज य सिस्टम एंड होस्ट बेस अटैक्स वर्क्स
द सेम वे सेम तरीके से काम करते हैं जो
एग्जांपल मैंने आपको लिया सिस्टम और होस्ट
बेस अटैक बिल्कुल एग्जैक्ट सेम योर
कंप्यूटर सर्वर्स और डिवाइस इज लाइक योर
हाउस एंड द एंट्री पॉइंट्स आर सॉफ्टवेयर
कॉन्फिडेंस एंड सेटिंग्स यह सारे के सारे
आपके दरवाजे खिड़कियां और गैरेज के रूप
में काम में आते हैं एंट्री पॉइंट के रूप
में और सिस्टम और बेस के केस में मैं बात
करूं सॉफ्टवेयर कॉन्फिन और सेटिंग्स इफ
देयर इज ए वलने बिलिटी लाइक एन आउटडेटेड
प्रोग्राम्स और ए वीक पासवर्ड इट्स लाइक
लीविंग योर विंडोज ओपन फॉर ए साइबर
अटैकर्स फॉर एग्जांपल इफ योर लिनक्स सर्वर
इज रनिंग एन ओल्ड वर्जन ऑफ अचे सर्वर ट्स
एन ओपन विंडो फॉर अटैकर्स या हम विंडोज की
बात करें इ विंडोज मशीन जज डिफॉल्ट एडमिन
पासवर्ड ट हैज नॉट बीन चेंज इट्स
लाइक हैंडिंग द की टू योर हाउस टू एनी वन
हु आस्क ओके अभी एग्जांपल समझ में आया कि
एग्जैक्ट आपको क्लियर हो गया होगा कि
सिस्टम और होस्ट बेस अटैक्स होते क्या
है एवरीवन गट
इट शायद अभी जिसको समझ में नहीं आया था वो
भी समझ में आ गया होगा मे बी दिस इज बिग
बेटर कंपैरिजन देन प्रीवियस लाइड्स और इस
और अभी भी नहीं समझ में आया तो एक
एग्जांपल बचा हुआ
है बिल्कुल यह सब मैं आपको समझा रहा हूं
कि आप लोग क्या करने वाले हो आज मैं सब
आपको इतना बताऊंगा कि हम अभी सिस्टम
हैकिंग के दौरान क्या करने वाले हैं यह
सारी चीजें प्रैक्टिकल है और यह सारी
चीजें आप जब इस कोर्स को कंप्लीट करोगे आप
के पास ये सारी नॉलेज
होगी ओके तो इन द कांटेक्ट ऑफ पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग वहाई इज दिस सो
इंपोर्टेंट व्हाई डू यू नीड टू गेट एन
अंडरस्टैंडिंग ऑफ सिस्टम और होस्ट बेस
अटैक्स इतना इंपॉर्टेंट क्यों है और मुझे
इसके बारे में क्यों जानकारी होनी चाहिए
मुझे नी इवन हर एक पेन टेस्टर को हर एक
एथिकल हैकर्स को या हर एक साइबर
सिक्योरिटी रिसर्चर को को या प्रोफेशनल को
इनकी जानकारी क्यों होनी चाहिए इसका कारण
बताता हूं फॉर
एग्जांपल यू आर हायर्ड बाय ए कंपनी एज ए
पेंटेस्टर एंड कंपनी प्रोवाइडेड एन आईपी
एड्रेस ऑफ पब्लिक फेसिक सर्वर ओके कंपनी
ने आपको यह आईपी एड्रेस प्रोवाइड किया
रैंडम आईपी एड्रेस में आपको लिया है
12276 आईपी एड्रेस और आप एक पेन टेस्टर हो
तो आपने क्या किया
कि इस आईपी एड्रेस पर आपने अपनी
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग की स्कैनिंग की
एन्यूमरेशन किया व एनालिसिस की और आपने इस
सर्वर का अब इस सर्वर के ऊपर बहुत सारी
चीजें बहुत सारी सर्विसेस रन करी थी मा
एसक्यूएल एसएसए एफटीपी या अपाचे वेब सर्वर
यह रन कर रहा था और एग्जांपल ले सकते हैं
कि अपाचे का अपडेटेड वर्जन रन कर रहा था
तो हैकर्स ने क्या किया अटैकर्स
ने इन इनम से किसी भी एक सर्विसेस का
फायदा उठाया और इस पब्लिक फेसिंग सर्वर का
क्या किया एक्सेस ले लिया एक्सप्लोइट करके
सेल एक्सेस ले लिया अटैकर्स ने ओके नाउ
एंड यू रिलाइज दैट पब्लिक फेसिंग सर्वर इज
आल्सो पार्ट ऑफ एन इंटरनल नेटवर्क एंड दैट
इंटरनल नेटवर्क हैज वेरियस सिस्टम्स और
होस्ट आर रनिंग कि जब उसने एनमने किया या
जब लोकल इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग की इस सिस्टम
के ऊपर तो हैकर ने पाया कि यह जो मेरा
सर्वर है जिसको मैंने कंप्रोमाइज किया है
यह किसी एक कंपनी के इंटरनल नेटवर्क का
पार्ट है जिसके ऊपर बहुत सारे होस्ट या
सिस्टम रन कर रहे हैं दीज इंटरनल होस्ट आर
नॉट द पार्ट ऑफ एन एक्सटर्नल नेटवर्क एंड
दे कैन नॉट बी एक्सेस्ड रिमोट थ्रू
इंटरनेट अभी जो इंटरनल पार्ट था यह आप
क्या कर सकते हो रिमोट एक्सेस नहीं कर
सकते इंटरनेट के थ्रू मतलब यह एक्सपोज
नहीं है एक्सटर्नली यह एक इंटरनल नेटवर्क
है बस यहां पर क्या है कि आपकी कंपनी की
गलती यह है कि जो एक सर्वर था जो पब्लिकली
एक्सेसिबल है वह इसके साथ जुड़ा हुआ है यह
इस नेटवर्क में है ओके इस नेटवर्क के साथ
वो कम्युनिकेट कर सकता है नाउ उसके बाद द
ओनली वे यू कैन एक्सेस देम इज थ्रू योर
कंप्रोमाइज होस्ट आप अगर इस नेटवर्क को
एक्सेस करना चाहते हो तो उसका एक ही तरीका
है यह जो कंप्रोमाइज सर्वर है इसके थ्रू
ही आप इस नेटवर्क को एक्सेस कर सकते हो सो
दिस इज वेयर होस्ट बेस अटैक्स कम इन टू
प्ले एंड दे एसेंशियली रिवॉल्व अराउंड
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
एंड देयर आर टू मोस्ट कॉमन ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम आर विज एंड
[संगीत]
मिस कन्फेशन ऑन द टारगेट ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
तो जब अब बात आती है सिस्टम और होस्ट बेस
अटैक की तो प्राइमर फोकस करती है कि जो भी
आपका ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है या जो भी आपका
सॉफ्टवेयर है तो उसकी जो इन्हेरेंट वनबिल
है वर्जन के स्पेसिफिक या कोई
भी जो सर्विस पैके के स्पेसिफिक या आपका
जो एप्लीकेशन रन कर रही है उसका भी जो
वर्जन के स्पेसिफिक या उसके जो मिस
कन्फर्स कन्फेशन है उसको सही से कन्फर
नहीं किया है यही चीज आती है आपके सिस्टम
एंड होस्ट बेस अटैक के अंदर यह प्राइमरी
इसी के ऊपर फोकस करता है अनलाइक नेटवर्क
बेस अटैक्स होस्ट बेस अटैक्स आर मच मोर
स्पेशलाइज्ड एंड रिक्वायर एन
अंडरस्टैंडिंग ऑफ टारगेट ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम्स एंड वल्नरेबल कीज दैट अफेक्ट सेड
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स ओके अभी नेटवर्क बेस
अटैक की बजाय जो होस्ट बेस अटैक्स होता है
उसमें आपको टारगेट ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स और
उससे रिलेटेड जो वनबिल है उसके बारे में
आपकी नॉलेज होनी बहुत ही ज्यादा जरूरी है
फॉर एग्जांपल लास्ट एग्जांपल लेते हैं हम
वी हैव
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
लैपटॉप्स एटस नाउ देन व्हाट वी डू नेक्स्ट
ओके हमने आइडेंटिफिकेशन
नेटवर्क का पार्ट है उस नेटवर्क में बहुत
वर्क स्टेशंस भी रन कर रहे हैं कुछ
एंप्लॉई के लैपटॉप्स भी है या
एक्सट्रा अभी जब हमने इंटरनल रिकॉन किया
या नेटवर्क स्कैनिंग की इंटरनल नेटवर्क
में थ्रू कंप्रोमाइज होस्ट तो हमने पता
लगाया कि इसके अंदर ना तो कोई एफटीपी
सर्विस रन कर रही ना कोई माय एसक्यूएल ना
ही कोई वेब सर्वर रन कर रहा है इस नेटवर्क
के अंदर इन दैट केस वी कैन टारगेट द
एंप्लॉई लैपटॉप दैट आर रनिंग विज 10 तो
हमें यह पता है कि कौन-कौन सा ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम रन कर रहा है तो हमने क्या किया
यहां पर एक एंप्लॉई का लैपटॉप था जो ws1
रन कर रहा था उसको हम ट टारगेट करते हैं
बट दे आर रनिंग एसएमबी सर्विस एंड अपार्ट
फ्रॉम द एसएमबी सर्विस दे आर नॉट रनिंग
एनी सर्विस व्हाई एसएमबी अब एसएमबी ही
क्यों क्योंकि किसी भी बड़ी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
के अंदर हर एक पीसी के अकॉर्डिंग
प्रिंटर्स प्लान नहीं किए जा सकते हमेशा
प्रिंटर्स को शेयर किया जाता है और जब
प्रिंटर को शेयर किया जाता है वहां पर
आपके नेट बायोस और आपका एसएमबी प्रोटोकॉल
का यूज किया जाता है दैट इज व्हाई यहां पर
प्रिंटर शेयरिंग थी और जब प्रिंटर शेयरिंग
थी तो एसएमबी प्रोटोकॉल का यूज हो रहा था
बिकॉज दे आर द पार्ट ऑफ इंटरनल नेटवर्क
एंड दे आर शेयरिंग ए प्रिंटर्स ऑफ फाइल्स
सो एसएमबी इज इनेबल्ड बाय डिफॉल्ट या तो
यह फाइल शेयर कर रहे हैं या प्रिंटर शेयर
कर रहे हैं तो इन दोनों ही केस में आपका
एसएमबी रन करेगा तो इमेजिन इफ यू आर एन
अटैकर और पेन टेस्टर एंड यू डोंट हैव द
अंडरस्टैंडिंग ऑफ इन्हेरेंट लिनेक्स और
वनटी अभी सोचिए कि आप एक पेंटेस्टर्स है
यह टास्क आप ही को दिया गया है और आपको जो
इन्हेरेंट जो वलने बिटीज है विंडोज की या
जो कन्फेशन फाइल की जो वलने बिटीज है उनके
बारे में आपको कोई भी नॉलेज नहीं है लेकिन
आप इस स्टेप पर आ गए तो उस केस में आपका
पेन टेस्टर होना या एक एथिकल सेकर होना एक
या साइबर सिक्योरिटी आप बोल सकते
प्रोफेशनल होना आपका नो वैल्यू कंपनी के
लिए आपकी कोई वैल्यू नहीं है आपको इस केस
में फायर कर देना चाहिए डायरेक्टली मैं
बोल रहा हूं बिकॉज यू हैव ओनली लर्न अबाउट
नेटवर्क बेस अटैक्स बट यू नेवर लर्न अबाउट
सिस्टम एंड होस्ट बेस अटैक्स आफ्टर यू हैव
द अंडरस्टैंडिंग ऑफ दीज यू आर एबल टू
स्टेज योर अटैक अगर आपके पास अगर इफ अगर
आपके पास इसकी नॉलेज है सिस्टम और होस्ट
बेस अटैक्स की तो आप अपने इस अटैक को एक
स्टेज प्रोवाइड कर सकते हो एक तरीके से
लेकर जा सकते हो यू विल बी एबल टू फाइंड
एन एक्सप्लोइट और ए वल्नरेबल विद इन
एसएमबी एसएमबी के अंदर आप वनटी फाइंड आउट
करने की कोशिश करोगे और वनटी को फाइंड आउट
करोगे देन दैट यू कुड एक्सप्लोइट टू गेन
एक्सेस टू दैट एंप्लॉय नेटवर्क और उसके
बाद क्या करोगे आप एंप्लॉई के लैपटॉप पे
रिमोट एक्सेस गेन कर लोगे ओके अगर आपको इन
सब की नॉलेज होगी तो तो दिस इज नॉट जस्ट
लिमिटेड टू एक्सप्लोइटेशन और गेनिंग एन
इनिशियल फुट होल्ड ऑन द होस्ट ऑफ द
नेटवर्क दैट आर रनिंग ऑन द इंटर नेटवर्क
जस्ट ओनली एक्सप्लोइटेशन और इनिशियल फुट
होल्ड या एंट्री पॉइंट तक ही सीमित नहीं
है जबकि यह आपके प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन की
जर्नी में भी वेरी वेरी हेल्पफुल ओके सो
दिस इज अ वेरी वेरी इंपोर्टेंट कोर्स एंड
दैट विल गिव यू स्पेशलाइज्ड नॉलेज इन
रिगार्ड्स टू इन्हेरेंट वलने बिटीज एंड
मिस कॉन्फिन विद इन विंडोज एंड
[संगीत]
ऑफ सिसम एंड होस्ट बेस अटैक्स व्हाट वी
विल व्हाट विल वी आर गोइंग टू लर्न
ड्यूरिंग दिस वल सेक्शन यह सारी चीजें मैं
आपको थ्रू द सीटीएफ आपको सारी चीजें
एक्सप्लेन करके समझाऊ कि एक्स हाउ टू
एक्सप्लोइट इन्हेरेंट वनबिल एंड मिस
कॉन्फिन विद इन लिनक्स ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स
हाउ टू एक्सप्लोइट इन्हेरेंट वनटी एंड मिस
कॉन्फिन विद इन विंडोज ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स
विंडोज फाइल सिस्टम की वलन बिलिटी को कैसे
फाइंड आउट करते हैं न फाइल सिस्टम वल को
कैसे फाइंड आउट करते हैं प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन वाया बोथ
[संगीत]
मेरे साथ-साथ इस कोर्स को फिनिश कीजिए देन
उसके बाद अनाउंसमेंट आपको मिलेगी और
नेक्स्ट सेम टाइम आप अभी अपने पैसे सेव
कीजिए और नेक्स्ट एडवांस कोर्स के लिए बी
वॉलंटिली कोई डाउट है एवरीवन गट
क्लियर यह था आपका सिस्टम और होस्ट बेस
अटैक की कहानी सबको शायद अभी कोई आपसे
पूछता भी है तो शायद आप एक एग्जांपल के
साथ किसी भी एक न्यू बेबी या एक प्रोफेशनल
को भी आप समझा सकते
हो कृष्णा प्रिंटर शेर का मतलब क्या होता
है कि जब भी आप क्या करते हो कि किसी भी
र्ग में काम करते हो तो आपका प्रिंटर भी
एक नेटवर्क में काम करता है जैसे आपका
आईपी एड्रेस होता है आपके मशीन का ऐसे ही
प्रिंटर भी आईपी एड्रेस पर काम करता हो
करता है और उस सेम नेटवर्क के अंदर जो जो
भी मशीन है उस प्रिंटर पर क्या कर सकती है
प्रिंट कमांड दे सकती है सिंपली एक ही
प्रिंटर के ऊपर
प्लीज बताइए बताइए
बताइए ओके सबको क्लियर है देखिए 51
स्टूडेंट से
48 मतलब कोई नहीं पढ़ना
चाहता मैन
ओके तो अभी बात करते हैं नेक्स्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन फेज अभी ये एक्सप्लोइटेशन
होता क्या है इस फज इस फेज में क्या-क्या
चीजें आती हैं आपकी ओके तो इसको एक्सप्लेन
एक्सप्लेन करूंगा मैं उसके बाद एक पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन फेज होता है उसमें कौन-कौन
से फेज और स्टेज आते हैं यह दोनों चीज आज
की स्लाइड में कवर होंगी आपको जस्ट आपको
फंडामेंटल्स बताया जाएगा कि एक्सप्लोइटेशन
के दौरान आप क्या-क्या सीखने वाले हो
पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन में आप क्या-क्या
सीखने वाले हो उसके बाद आज सेशन को एंड
करेंगे देन उसके बाद हम नेक्स्ट सेशन से
हमारे प्रैक्टिकल स्टार्ट करेंगे ओके तो
अभी बात करते हैं व्ट इंट्रोडक्शन टू
एक्सप्लोइटेशन ओके अभी मैं चैट सेक्शन
आपका देख नहीं रहा हूं
[संगीत]
तो एक्सप्लोइटेशन कंसिस्ट ऑफ टूल्स एंड
टेक्निक्स दैट आर यूज्ड बाय पेनेट्रेशन
टेस्टर्स टू गेन एन इनिशियल फुट होल्ड ऑन
ए टारगेट सिस्टम और नेटवर्क मींस वी कैन
से दैट वी हैव आइडेंटिफिकेशन
वी आर गोइंग टू गेन एक्सेस टू ए टारगेट
सिस्टम और नेटवर्क शायद ये लाइन आपको समझ
में नहीं आई आई होगी मैं आपको बता देता
हूं एक्सप्लोइटेशन वह प्रोसेस है जिसमें
पेंटेस्टर्स कुछ स्पेसिफिक टूल्स और
टेक्निक का यूज
करके आपका जो टारगेट का जो टारगेट सिस्टम
है या जो नेटवर्क है उसमें एंट्री पॉइंट
एंट्री करते हैं ओके एक इनिशियल फुट होल्ड
ट्राई करते हैं मतलब एक पहला कदम रख
उस टारगेट के साथ अपना एक्सेस गेन करने के
लिए ओके इसका मतलब कि हमें टारगेट के अंदर
की वनबिल का पता है मुझे जो एक टारगेट है
उसके अंदर की वलन बिलिटी का पता है और अभी
मैं उस वनटी का फायदा उठाकर सिस्टम के
अंदर एक्सेस कर सकता हूं ओके इनिशियल
एक्सेस समझ में आ गया इनिशियल एक्सेस मतलब
पहला एक्सेस जिस फर्स्ट स्टेप होता जो
आपका एक्सप्लोइटेशन
तो यही है इसका
मतलब फॉर एग्जांपल मैं आपको समझाता हूं
जैसे अगर आपने कभी भी देखा होगा कि कोई भी
वेबसाइट है उसका अगर लॉगिन पेज इनसिक्योर
है जहां पर आप क्या कर सकते हो ब्रूट
फोर्स अटैक ट्राई करके वहां के उसके
पासवर्ड को गेस कर सकते हो तो वह आपका एक
एक्सप्लोइटेशन का एग्जांपल है मतलब आपने
ब्रूट फोर्स ट्राई किया आपको यूजर नेम और
पासवर्ड मिल गया उस लॉगिन फॉर्म का आप एक
ऑथेंटिकेट यूजर के रूप में आपने उसके अंदर
वेबसाइट के अंदर एंट्री की तो वह भी एक
एग्जांपल आपका एक्सप्लोइटेशन
का तो सक्सेसफुल एक्सप्लोइटेशन विल हैवली
डिपेंड ऑन द नेचर एंड क्वालिटी ऑफ
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग एंड सर्विस एमेशन
परफॉर्म द टारगेट अभी कोई भी आपका जो
एक्सप्लोइटेशन का सक्सेस होने का एक ही
कारण है कि आपके पास किस टाइप की
इंफॉर्मेशन है अपने टारगेट से रिलेटेड
जितनी क्वालिटी या क्वालिटी भरी आपकी
इंफॉर्मेशन होगी जितनी ज्यादा आपके पास
इंफॉर्मेशन होगी और जितनी अच्छी क्वालिटी
में इंफॉर्मेशन होगी मतलब करेक्ट और जितनी
सर्विसेस की आपके पास इंफॉर्मेशन होगी
पोर्ट उसके वर्जन उतने ज्यादा चांसेस आपके
बढ़ जाते हैं किसी भी टारगेट को एकस लोट
करने
के नाउ एक स्टेटमेंट है इसको समझने की
कोशिश करना वी कैन ओनली एक्सप्लोइट ए
टारगेट इफ वी नो व्हाट इज वल्नरेबल चलो
इसको थोड़ा सा सिंपल करते हैं यू विल यू
विल नॉट नो व्ट टू एक्सप्लोइट एंड हाउ टू
एक्सप्लोइट ए पर्टिकुलर सर्विस अनलेस यू
नो इफ इट्स वल्नरेबल शायद दोनों चीज आपको
समझ में नहीं आई होगी थर्ड चीज है यू कैन
नॉट एक्सप्लोइट सर्विस अनलेस यू नो इट इज
वल्नरेबल किसी सर्विस को तब तक एक्सप्लोइट
नहीं कर सकते जब तक आपको यह नहीं पता हो
कि वह वल्नरेबल है उसके अंदर कमियां है
दिस मींस इट इज एसेंशियल टू फर्स्ट
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
मेशन ओनली देन वी कैन डिटरमाइंड व्हिच
एक्सप्लोइट वुड बी इफेक्टिव जो ये लाइन है
यह लाइन अपने आप में एक बहुत गहरा मतलब
छुपा के रखती है कि आप किसी चीज को तब तक
एक्सप्लोइट नहीं कर सकते या उसके लिए तब
तक परफेक्ट एक्सप्लोइट नहीं फाइंड आउट कर
सकते जब तक आपको यह नहीं पता हो कि वह
सर्विस आपकी वल्नरेबल है और यह स ये
इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट करने के लिए आपको उस
सर्विस को पूरी तरह एनालाइज करना पड़ेगा
एग्जैक्ट वर्जन इंफॉर्मेशन होना चाहिए हो
सके उसकी कॉन्फिन फाइल्स हो आपके पास और
उसकी पोटेंशियल वल्नरेबल की आपके पास
नॉलेज होनी चाहिए उसी केस में आप एक उसके
लिए एक बेटर एक्सप्लोइट क्या कर सकते हो
सजेस्ट कर सकते हो फाइंड आउट कर सकते हो
और देन ओनली आप क्या कर सकते हो उस सिस्टम
को एक्सप्लोइट कर सकते हो ये एक ऐसी ऐसी
स्टेटमेंट है अगर इस स्टेटमेंट को पढ़ोगे
आपको समझ में नहीं आएगी बट इस स्टेटमेंट
को मैंने आपके सामने एक्सप्लेन कर दिया है
तो वी कैन ओनली एक्सप्लोइट अ टारगेट इफ वी
नो व्हाट इज वल्नरेबल
नेक्स्ट इन दिस सेक्शन वी विल यूज वेरियस
टूल्स एंड टेक्निक्स ट एसेंशियली इवॉल्वड
इन द एक्सप्लोइटेशन प्रोसेस इस सेक्शन के
अंदर बहुत सारे टूल्स और टेक्निक्स यूज
करने वाले हैं जो आपकी एक्सप्लोइटेशन
प्रोसेस का पार्ट है चलो मैं आपको समझाता
हूं कि एक्सप्लोइटेशन परफॉर्म करने की एक
मेथड होती है उसकी भी एक तरीका है कि दज
आर द फॉलोइंग फॉलो बाय मेनी अदर पेंटेस्टर
एंड रेट मर्स अभ ये जो मैं आपको मेथड्स
बता रहा हूं जो टेक्निक्स बता रहा हूं जो
तरीके बता रहा हूं यह मैक्सिमम 90 पर पेन
टेस्टर्स के द्वारा यूज किए जाते हैं सबसे
पहले हम क्या करते हैं आइडेंटिफिकेशन
या आपका पावर सेल एंपायर उनके फ्रेमवर्क
के द्वारा य आपका चाहे वो अवेलेबल हो तो
आपको क्या करना है उस सर्विस के अकॉर्डिंग
उस एक्सप्लोइट कोड को
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
उसके बाद आप क्या ऑब्टेन रिमोट एक्सेस ऑन
द टारगेट सिस्टम उसके बाद आप क्या क्या
करते हो यह सार सीक्वेंस में काम करती है
1 2 3 4 सो इट डज नॉट एंड योर जर्नी बाय
जस्ट एक्सप्लोइटिंग अ सर्विस बिकॉज
एक्सप्लोइट कोड माइट नॉट नेसेसरीली
प्रोवाइड यू विद रिमोट एक्सेस ओके कि
जरूरी नहीं है कि आपको एक्सप्लोइट कोड
रिमोट एक्सेस प्रोवाइड करें इट मे ओनली
एग्जीक्यूट कमांड ऑन द टारगेट नॉट मच मोर
हो सकता है कि वो एक्सप्लो आपको सब कुछ
कमांड एग्जीक्यूट ही करके दे तो उस केस
में हम क्या करते हैं मैं आपको बताता हूं
नेक्स्ट स्लाइड प चलता हूं यह रहा तो दिस
इज वयर वल आईडिया ऑफ रिवर्स सेल्स एंड
पेलोड्स कम इन टू प्ले अभी जब व आपको
सिनेरियो आ जाता है कि एक्सप्लोइट आपको
कोई रिमोट एक्सेस प्रोवाइड नहीं कर रहा है
तो उस केस में आप रिवर्स सेल का यूज करते
हो या बाइंडर का यूज करते हो या पेलोड का
यूज करते हो वंस यू एक्सप्लोइट ए सर्विस
यू नीड रिवर्स सेल और यू नीड टू ऑब्टेन
एक्सेस टू ए टारगेट सिस्टम आप को टारगेट
सिस्टम का एक्सेस चाहिए होता है एंड दिस
इज वेरी वेरी
इंपोर्टेंट फेज ऑफ
एक्सप्लोइटेशन वंस यू गेन एक्सेस टू अ
टारगेट सिस्टम देन मे बी हाई चांसेस दैट
दिस सिस्टम माइट नॉट बी प्रिविलेज सिस्टम
और माइट नॉट द डाटा हैव यू आर लुकिंग फॉर
अभी यह 100% ट्रू है कि जब किसी भी टारगेट
सिस्टम को आप एक्सेस गेन करते हो तो वहां
पर 100% चांसेस हो होते हैं कि आपको वो
प्रिविलेज एक् सिस्टम आपको जो एक्सेस मिले
वो प्रिविलेज्ड ना हो मतलब एडमिन एक्सेस
ना हो वहां पर उस यूजर्स के लिए कोई भी
एक्सेस ना हो या फर्द उस डायरेक्टरी से
बाहर या उस फोल्डर से बाहर आप कहीं पर कुछ
परफॉर्म ही ना कर पाए या वहां पर आप कुछ
मॉडिफाई ना कर पाए वहां पर राइट की परमिश
ना हो तो एंड माइट नॉट बी डाटा हो सकता है
कि जो डाटा फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश कर
रहे हो जो आप फाइंड आउट कर रहे हो वो डाटा
वहां पर ना हो उस केस में क्या करते हैं
सो एज ए पेन टेस्टर यू नीड टू कंप्रो एज
मेनी सिस्टम्स एज यू कैन ऑन ए टारगेट
नेटवर्क उस केस में आप क्या करते हो इन
चीजों को फाइंड आउट करने के लिए जितने
सिस्टम हो सकते हैं उस नेटवर्क के अंदर आप
सारे के सारे क्या करते हो कंप्रोमाइज
करने की कोशिश करते हो एज ए पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टर एंड फॉर दैट यू आल्सो नीड टू
एबिलिटी टू
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
जो पर्टिकुलर सिस्टम है उससे रिलेटेड आपको
लोकल एन्यूमरेशन परफॉर्म करना आना चाहिए
आपको पोर्ट फॉरवर्डिंग करनी आनी चाहिए
आपको टनलिंग परफॉर्म करनी आनी चाहिए आपको
पिवेट परफॉर्म करना आना चाहिए अगर आप एक
सिस्टम से दूसरे सिस्टम पर शिफ्ट करना
चाहते हैं उस नेटवर्क के अंदर ओके तो
इसलिए सारी की सारी मैथोलॉजी होती है
बायपास एंटीवा डिटेक्शन पिवो ऑन अदर
सिस्टम इसलिए सारी कहानी किसकी होती है
आपकी एक्सप्लोइटेशन फेज की तो मैं भी अभी
एवन गट क्लियर यहां तक सबको समझ में
आया यस टनलिंग क्या होती है पिटिंग क्या
होती है वो पोर्ट फॉरवर्डिंग कैसे करते
हैं यह भी मैं आपको मेटा स्लेट के थ्रू
बता दूंगा यह पार्ट है बेसिक लेवल पर
फंडामेंटल लेवल पर पोर्ट फोर्डिंग कैसे
होती है टनलिंग कैसे करते हैं और पिवेट
कैसे करते हैं इस कोर्स में आपको पढ़ाऊंगा
और सिस्टम हैकिंग के अंदर ही पढ़ाऊंगा
थोड़ा सा वेट कीजिए बट मैं आपको पढ़ाऊंगा
100%
पट फॉरवर्डिंग मैनुअल भी आप सीख सकते हो
मैनुअल एडवांस कोर्स का पार्ट है बट आपको
एक अच्छा तरीका बता दूंगा उसके थ्रू आप कर
सकते हो एक बेसिक लेवल पर और एडवांस लेवल
पर सीखने के लिए यही सारी चीजें अगर आपको
टनलिंग करनी है पोर्ट फोल्डिंग करनी है
खुद के टूल्स पाइथन में क्रिएट करके भी
करनी है तो वो भी आप कर सकते हो बट वोह
हमारे डीसीएसपी कोर्स होता है जिसमें
नेटवर्क प आपने देखा नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी
है जहां पर नेटवर्क में टूल बनाने बनाए
जाते हैं वहां पर ये सारी चीजें आपको
बारीकी से समझाई जाती है कि आप पहले
नेटवर्क सीखते हो नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी देन
उसके बाद पाइथन की हेल्प से पूरी नेटवर्क
प्रोग्रामिंग सीख लेते
हो या एवी वेजन टेक्निक्स भी मैं आपको
बेसिक लेवल पर सिखाऊंगा
हां एक्सप्लोइटेशन मैं आपको बता रहा हूं
रुको नेक्स्ट स्लाइड प चलते हैं इन द
कांटेक्ट ऑफ एक्सप्लोइटेशन फेज सभी का वही
जो आप मुझसे पूछना चाह हो मोस्ट आस्क डाउट
क्या है कि व्हाट विल ब आर गोइंग टू लर्न
ड्यूरिंग दिस वल जर्नी इस पर्टिकुलर पूरी
की पूरी जर्नी में हम एक्सप्लोइटेशन
रिलेटेड सर क्या-क्या चीजें सीखने वाले
हैं जो आप सभी का सवाल है मैं उसका जवाब
देता हूं यह रहा वल्नट स्कैनिंग कि य वी
विल लर्न हाउ टू स्कैन एंड डिटेक्ट वलने
बिलिटी ऑन ए टारगेट सिस्टम ये हम सीखने
वाले हैं हाउ टू डिटेक्ट वलन बिलिटी ऑन ए
पर्टिकुलर सर्विस दैट इज रनिंग ऑन ए
टारगेट सिस्टम सर्चिंग फॉर एक्सप्लोइट आइर
ऑनलाइन और लोकली ऑफलाइन ओके दोनों ही
तरीके से मैं आपको सिखाऊंगा कि एक्सप्लोर
को कैसे आपको ऑनलाइन फाइंड आउट करना है या
लोकली फाइंड आउट करना है उसके बाद उसको
कैसे कंपाइल करना है जैसे फिक्सिंग
एक्सप्लोइट हाउ टू कंपाइल एंड मॉडिफाई द
एक्सप्लोइट फॉर द यूज ड्यूरिंग
एक्सप्लोइटेशन ओके और एक्सप्लोइट को जब आप
कंपाइल कर रहे हो या उसको जब आप
एक्सप्लोइट को यूज करने वाले हो किन-किन
बातों को आपको ध्यान में ध्यान देना चाहिए
क्या-क्या पॉइंट्स आपको कंसीडर करने चाहिए
चाहे वो लोकली हो चाहे वो आप पन टेस्ट
एग्जाम दे रहे हो उस केस में तो सारी
चीजें हम आपको ड्यूरिंग दिस जर्नी
ड्यूरिंग लैब्स जब यह टॉपिक आएगा कि ज मैं
एक्सलेट फाइंड आउट करूंगा वाया ऑनलाइन या
ऑफलाइन तो उसमें यह टैक्टिक्स मैं आपको
सिखा दूंगा कि दोनों तरीके से हम कैसे
फाइंड आउट करते हैं सर्च पलट का भी हम यूज
करेंगे उसके बाद उस एक्सप्लोइट को फिक्स
कैसे करते हैं कि पर्टिकुलर एक्सप्लोइट और
सेफ मतलब सेफ तरीका कहां है कि मैं कि
सेफली की उस एक्सट को अपने सिस्टम में
लेले लेकर आ पाऊ और मेरा सिस्टम को कोई
नुकसान भी ना पहुंचे यह चीज मैं आपको बता
दूंगा देन बाइड एंड रिवर्स सेल दे प्ले
पिटल रोल इन एक्सप्लोइटेशन एंड गेनिंग
रिमोट एक्सेस टू ए टारगेट सिस्टम ड्यूरिंग
दिस सेक्शन वी विल गेट एन इंट्रो
अंडरस्टैंडिंग ऑफ बाइड एंड रिवर्स सेल एंड
आल्सो हाउ दे कैन बी ऑब्टेंड ऑन बोथ
विंडोज एंड लिनक्स ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम बेसिक
लेवल पर मैं आपको बता दूंगा कि बाइंडर
रिवर्स सेल होता क्या है कैसे हम बाइंडर
ले सकते विज या
चीजें मैं आपको बता दूंगा माइंड और
रिवर्सल में क्या डिफरेंस होता है यह भी
आपको फंडामेंटल यहां पर क्लियर कर
दूंगा ओके देन उसके बाद एक्सप्लोइटेशन
फ्रेमवर्क मैट पलट फ्रेमवर्क और पावर
सेल्फ एंपायर मेटास फ्रेमवर्क आप पढ़ चुके
हैं पावर सेल एंपायर के बारे में आपको बता
दूंगा एक्सप्लोइटेशन फ्रेमवर्क वाला तो जो
ड्यूरिंग जो लैब्स एक्सप्लोइटेशन
फ्रेमवर्क यूज होने वाला सिर्फ वही
एक्सप्लेन करेंगे कंप्लीट एक्सप्लोइटेशन
फ्रेमवर्क मैं आपको एक्सप्लेन नहीं करूंगा
क्योंकि आपको खुद से करना चाहिए क्योंकि
आपको एक बार एक्सप्लोइटेशन फ्रेमवर्क यूज
करना आ गया देन आप खुद से यूज कर सकते हो
देन
होता क्या है और एक्सप्लोइटेशन फेज में हम
क्या सीखने वाले हैं कमिंग वन एंड हाफ मंथ
में जो टोटल जलनी रहेगी ओनली सिस्टम
हैकिंग
की कृष्णा आपको डाटा अगर यह एरर आ रही है
पहली बात तो आपको मैंने या तो आप मेरी
पूरी वीडियो देखते नहीं मैंने आपको बोला
कि अगर कोई भी डाउट आप लोगों को मुझे
मुझसे पूछना है तो जब वीडियो अपलोड हो
जाती है तो उस वीडियो के कमेंट सेक्शन को
आप कमेंट और चीजें कमेंट करने की ना बजाय
आप वहां पर डाउट लिख के ये डाउट पूछ सकते
हो ओके अभी क्या है कि मैं आप पढ़ा कुछ
रहा हूं इस टॉपिक को छोड़कर मुझे मेटा
स्टूडेंट पे जाना पड़ेगा दिस इज नॉट द गुड
गुड वे आपका डाउट है तो आप सेशन के एंड
में बने रहिए इसको मैं रिजॉल्व कर दूंगा
आपको वेट करना पड़ेगा अब इस सेशन के बीच
में ऐसे डिस्टर्ब मत किया करो यार प्लीज
आई रिक्वेस्ट क्योंकि एक टॉपिक चल रहा
होता है उस टॉपिक से रिलेटेड अभी पूछिए
मैं आपको मना नहीं करर आपका डाउट सॉल्व
नहीं होगा आपका डाउट डेफिनेटली सॉल्व होगा
बट या तो एंड ऑफ द क्लास पूछिए या फिर आप
कमेंट सेक्शन में पूछिए और अभी तक मैंने
जितने भी लोगों ने कमेंट किए सबका मैंने
आंसर
किया अब्दुल बेस्ट मैं आपको एक्सप्लेन कर
दूंगा यह सिर्फ मैं आपको बताऊ य सारे
टॉपिक मैं करवाने वाला हूं एक्सप्लो के
थ्रू इनको मैं एक्सप्लेन कर दूंगा कि यह
कैसे काम करते हैं डोंट वरी चिंता मत
कीजिए बस यह क्या इंट्रो पार्ट है कि जो
आप करने वाले ड्यूरिंग दिस
कोर्स चले अभी पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन फेज
पर सॉरी नहीं चाहिए कृष्णा बस मेरे साथ
थोड़ा सा कंप्रोमाइज कीजिए बस थोड़ा सा
पेशेंस रखिए और थोड़ा कंट्रीब्यूट कीजिए
दो ही चीज चाहिए आपके सारे सवालों के जवाब
भी मिलेंगे आपको एक अच्छी नॉलेज के लिए
एंपावर भी किया जाएगा और
भी हेल्प किया जाएगा आपको जब भी जरूरत
होगी बस सही टाइम पर सही चीजों को पूछिए
सो दैट कि आपका भी टाइम वेस्ट ना हो बाकी
स्टूडेंट्स का भी टाइम वेस्ट ना
हो इन सबका प्रैक्टिकल्स
होगा जो भी चीजें मैंने अभी आपको स्लाइड
में दिखा रहा हूं यह सारे आपके
प्रैक्टिकल्स का पार्ट है अगर किसी लब
लैब्स में परफॉर्म नहीं कि जाएंगे तो मैं
आपको एक प्रैक्टिकल्स दिखा दूंगा
डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक का ऑलरेडी कोर्स डेनिक्स
प एक सर्टिफिकेशन कोर्स ऑलरेडी चलता है
और कार्डिंग वगैरह के लिए कोर्स ऑलरेडी
अवेलेबल है कांटेक्ट कीजिए और दूसरा आपने
बोला सर अदर कैटेगरी का कोर्स एडवांस पेन
टेस्टिंग बूट कैंप भी आएगा आपको ओनली बूट
कैंप आएगा और अगर उसको फुल सिक्स मंथ
डिप्लोमा चाहिए आप वह भी ज्वाइन कर सकते
हो डीसीएसपी और देन उसके बाद शोक एनालिस्ट
भी जल्दी कोर्स आने वाला है एंड्र पेन
टेस्टिंग की अनाउंसमेंट होने वाली है तो
सारी चीजें और डीसीसीआई डीसीआई जो साइबर
क्राइम इन्वेस्टिगेशन ऑलरेडी अभी 11 तारीख
से स्टार्ट है तो उसकी ऑलरेडी बुकिंग ओपन
है और डीसीएसपी कोर्स चल रहा है तो यह
सारे कोर्स ऑलरेडी पैरेलल में चल रहे हैं
भैया तो आप उसको वहां से जवाइन कर सकते हो
यस समप्रीत एडवांस के जो भी कोर्सेस होंगे
इवन जब मैं आपको एडवांस अगर वर्कशॉप भी
करवाता हूं किसी भी ओनली अगर प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन से या आपको ओनली मैं एनोनिमस
जहां पर मैं आपको कोशिश करूंगा कि हाउ टू
स्टे एनोनिमस वह चीज भी यह सारी अगर जो
एडवांस टॉपिक रहेंगे उनकी एक मिनिमम
अमाउंट के साथ हमें पेमेंट बेसिस रखना
क्योंकि वहां पर मुझे भी अभी उनको फ्री
नहीं करवा सकता क्योंकि वहां पर बहुत
ज्यादा हाई लेवल स्ट्राइक आ जाएगा दूसरा
यार आई एम आल्सो मुझे भी एक एक थोड़ा सा
मुझे स आप समझिए मैं झूठ नहीं बोल रहा
आपको ना घुमा रहा हमें भी तो थोड़े बहुत
पैसे चाहिए यार बट आपको इतने इतना अ श्योर
है कि यहां पर क्वालिटी प्लस प्रीमियम
मिलेगा कभी भी आपके साथ कोई भी झोलझाल
नहीं किया
जाएगा शॉक फ्री नहीं होगा शॉक फ्री नहीं
करवा सकता क्योंकि शॉक एटलीस्ट फोर टू फ
मंथ का कोर्स होगा
चलो नेक्स्ट चलते हैं पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन
फेज ए गुड हैकर नोज हाउ टू गेट इन ए ग्रेट
वन नोज व्हाट टू डू आफ्टर यह स्टेटमेंट एक
गहरा रात छुपाए हुए बैठी है मतलब एक अच्छा
हैकर यह जानता है कि अंदर कैसे जाना है
लेकिन एक ग्रेट हैकर्स होता है जो ग्रेट
वन जो प्रोफेशनल्स होते हैं वो यह जानते
हैं कि इसके बाद मुझे क्या करना है यह
दोनों स्टेटमेंट अपने आप में एक बहुत डीप
स्टेटमेंट है गुड हैकर की बात ओनली
एक्सप्लोइटेशन जानता है और ग्रेट हैकर की
बात यहां पर बात आती है आपकी पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन फेज के बारे में उसके पास
इंफॉर्मेशन है ओके
चलो इन द कांटेक्ट ऑफ पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग
अब एक डाउट होगा सर वंस वी एक्सप्लोइट
सिस्टम व्ट डू वी डू एंड ट द पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्ट एंड देयर सर एक बार हम किसी सिस्टम
को एक्सप्लोइट कर लेते हैं उसमें एक्सेस
गेन कर लेते हैं या इनिशियल फुट होल्ड रख
लेते हैं उसके बाद हम क्या करें क्या जो
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग की जो जर्नी है यहां
पर खत्म हो जाती है बताइए
बताइए
बताइए एनी वन कोई भी आंसर
करेगा यस वेरी गुड नो
क्योंकि जो सबसे लास्ट स्टेज है मोस्ट
इंपोर्टेंट स्टेज है वह आता है आपका पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन तो सबसे पहले हम जानते हैं
अब पोस्ट एक्सप्लोरेशन के बाद भी एक चीज
होती है रिपोर्टिंग अब रिपोर्टिंग तो आप
[संगीत]
टकस पेंटेस्टर्स एडवर्सरीज अंडरटेक आफ्टर
ऑब्टेनिंग इनिशियल एक्सेस ऑन ए टारगेट
सिस्टम जो पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन होता आपका
किसी भी पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग लाइफ साइकिल
का फाइनल फेज होता है जिसके अंदर देर लॉट
ऑफ टेक्निक्स टैक्टिक्स और प्रोसीजर्स
होते हैं जो किसी भी अटैकर्स या पेंटेस्टर
के द्वारा परफॉर्म किए जाते हैं जब एक बार
वह सिस्टम को एक्सप्लोइट कर लेता है
इनिशियल एक्सेस गेन कर लेता है किसी भी
टारगेट के ऊपर इन अदर वर्ड्स इट इवॉल्व
व्हाट यू डू और हैव टू डू वंस यू गेन एन
इनिशियल फुट होल्ड ऑन द टारगेट सिस्टम फु
फुट होल्ड की यहां पर बात आती है आपका
एंट्री पॉइंट एक बार और सिस्टम में एक्सेस
गेन कर लेता है तो उसके बाद मुझे क्या
करना है और कैसे करना है यह सारी चीजें
आपकी पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन फेज के अंदर आती
है
नाउ एक और चीज है जो आपको हमेशा याद रखनी
है वंस यू हैव गेन एन इनिशियल फुटहोल्ड या
गेन एक्सेस ऑन ए टारगेट
नेटवर्क यू नीड टू बी फाइंड अदर सिस्टम्स
दैट यू कैन एक्सप्लोर ंड नेटवर्क हमेशा
आपको एज ए पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर आपको यह चीज
ध्यान में रखनी है जब आपको एक बार किसी
सिस्टम के अंदर एक्सेस गेन हो जाता है
आपको एक्सेस मिल जाता है तो आपको वहां पर
और भी सिस्टम फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश
करनी है और उनको भी फर्द एक्सप्लोइट करना
चा आइए दिस इज द रिस्पांसिबिलिटी ऑफ ए
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर
बिकॉज रिमेंबर एज ए पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर यू
हैव हायर्ड टू टारगेट द एंटायस जब भी आपको
किसी भी नेटवर्क के ऊपर पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग करने के लिए बोला जाता है तो
आपको किसी एक पर्टिकुलर सिस्टम पे
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग करने के लिए नहीं
बोला जाता वहां पर आपको बोला जाता है पूरे
नेटवर्क के ऊपर तो दिस इज योर
रिस्पांसिबिलिटी अगर आपको किसी एक नेटवर्क
में या एक सिस्टम में अगर आपको एक्सप्लोइट
मिलता है एक्सेस मिलता है देन इट्स योर
रिस्पांसिबिलिटी पहले तो ये पता करो
कि उसके अंदर और भी होस्ट है यानी या किसी
अदर इंटरनल नेटवर्क का पार्ट तो नहीं है
अगर वो किसी इंटरनल नेटवर्क का पार्ट है
तो उसको वहां पर प्रिविलेज एलेशन ट्राई
करो प्रिविलेज एकशन ट्राई करके उसके बाद
फर्द वेटिंग करो उस दूसरे सिस्टम पर मूव
करो उसको एक्सप्लोइट करने की ट्राई करो तो
दे आर लॉट ऑफ स्टेप्स आर अवेलेबल पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन फेज एक ऐसा फेज होता है
जहां पर आप जब भी किसी एक सिस्टम को
एक्सप्लोइट कर लेते हो उस पर पोस्ट
एक्सप्लो परफॉर्म कर लेते हो फिर से जैसे
ही आप उसको मूव करते हो तो नेक्स्ट स्टेज
पर भी क्या होता है फिर से पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोरेशन सर्कल स्टार्ट होता है अगर
फिर वो भी आपने एक्सप्लोइट कर लिया अगर थ
आप थर्ड सिस्टम प शिफ्ट करते हो किसी भी
नेटवर्क के अंदर तो फिर से फिर जीरो से
पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन स्टार्ट होता है तो
पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन एक ऐसी साइकिल है जो
हमेशा रिपीटेडली चलती रहती है वो कभी
स्टॉप नहीं होती ओके नाउ
वन इंपॉर्टेंट थिंग यू नीड टू टेक इनटू
कंसीडरेशन इज दैट पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन विल
डिफर बेस्ड ऑन द टारगेट ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
एज वेल एज टारगेट इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर अभी जो
पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन है पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन फेज के दौरान जितने भी
टूल्स और टेक्निक्स का यूज किया जाता है
वह हमेशा आपकी दो चीजों पर डिपेंड करता है
एक तो टारगेट ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम आपका टारगेट
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम कौन सा है विंडोज है है
या
होती है वह सारी की सारी वेरी करती है
अकॉर्डिंग टू दीज टू फीचर्स टारगेट
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स और टारगेट
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर
द पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन टेक्निक्स एंड
टूल्स दैट यू कैन यूज विल आल्सो डिपेंड ऑन
व्हाट काइंड ऑफ एक्सेस यू हैव ऑन द सिस्टम
दैट यू कंप्रोमाइज बेसिकली मेरा कहने का
मतलब यह है कि जो पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन की
जो टेक्निक्स और टूल्स हैं एक और फैक्टर
पर डिपेंड करती है कि आपको सिस्टम के अंदर
किस टाइप का एक्सेस मिला है एक बार आपने
उस सिस्टम को कंप्रोमाइज कर लिया
कंप्रोमाइज करने के लिए आपको क्या एक
स्टैंडर्ड यूजर का एक्सेस मिला है या आपको
एक प्रिविलेज्ड एक्सेस मिला है एडमिन
एक्सेस मिला है यह भी फैक्टर बहुत मायने
रखता है फॉर एग्जांपल एज ए पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टर यू हैव जस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेड ए विंडो
सिस्टम एंड द डिफॉल्ट प्रिविलेजेस दैट यू
हैव ऑब्टेंड थ्रू दिस एक्सप्लोइटेशन आर
नॉट प्रिविलेज बेसिकली एज ए पेन टेस्टर जब
आप एक विंडोज सिस्टम को टारगेट कर रहे थे
आपने उसको एक्सप्लोइट किया और वहां पर
डिफॉल्ट प्रिविलेज आपको जो मिले आपको
आफ्टर एक्सप्लोइटेशन वो नॉट प्रिविलेज
मतलब आपको जो अकाउंट मिला वह
अनप्रिविलेज्ड यूजर अकाउंट मिला मतलब आपको
वहां पर कोई भी प्रिविलेजेस नहीं है तो इन
दैट केस टेक्निक्स एंड टूल्स दैट यू कैन
यूज विल डिफरेंट देन इफ यू हैव गेन एक्सेस
टू टारगेट सिस्टम एज एन एलिवेटेड यूजर
मतलब इस केस में आपके जो जो भी टूल्स और
टेक्निक का यूज किया जाएगा अन प्रिविलेज
यूजर के केस में वह अलग होंगी अगर आपका
यहां पर प्रिविलेज यूजर होता एलिवेटेड
यूजर्स होता मतलब एडमिन एक्सेस होते तो उस
केस में जो भी टैक्टिक्स और टूल का यूज
किया जाता वो अलग होता तो यह चीजें जो
कहानी है यह आपकी वेरी करती है एक तो आपका
टारगेट ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम टारगेट
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर और आपको टारगेट के ऊपर
किस टाइप का एक्सेस मिला है उन्हीं के
बेसिस पर जो टारगेट जो पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन के फेज है वो वैरी करते हैं
कोई फेज स्किप हो जाता है या पूरे पूरे
फेज यूज होते हैं व फेज कौन से होते हैं
वो स्टेज कौन से होते हैं आई विल
एक्सप्लेन टुडे मींस इफ यू वांट टू डंप
फसेस एंड क्रेडेंशियल फॉर दैट यू एक्चुअली
नीड टू एलिवेटेड योर प्लेजेस क्योंकि बहुत
सारे फैक्टर्स होते हैं जब भी आप किसी
मशीन में एडवांस लेवल की पेन टेस्टिंग
करना चाहते हो एडवांस लेवल पे आप हैकिंग
करना चाहते हो उस केस में आपको उन फैक्टर
को फुलफिल करना होता जैसे कि अगर आपको डंप
हैसे है उनको डंप करना है या एनटीएल एमस
को डंप करना है या स्ल टीसी पड फाइल के जो
पासवर्ड को डम करना है और उस और आपको एक
लेजिटीमेट यूजर के रूप में सिस्टम के अंदर
एक्सेस करना है तो उस केस में आपको क्या
करना पड़ेगा आपके पास उस मशीन का हायर
लेवल का रूट लेवल का या एडमिन लेवल का
एक्सेस होना चाहिए अब वो परफॉर्म करने के
लिए आपको कुछ टूल्स और टेक्निक्स अलग यूज
करनी पड़ेंगी अगर
आपका जो प्रिज यूजर है
उसकी बजाय तो द पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन
टेक्निक यू कैन रन अगेंस्ट द टारगेट विल
नीड टू अाइड द रूल्स ऑफ एंगेजमेंट दैट यू
एग्रीड अपॉन विद द क्लाइंट बिफोर द
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग अभी एक चीज हमेशा
आपको ध्यान में रखनी है कि जब भी आप पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन टेक्निक का यूज करते हो तो
आपको हमेशा कि रूल्स ऑफ इंगेजमेंट का
ध्यान रखना है मतलब जब भी आप क्या करते हो
किसी भी कंपनी के लिए या किसी भी कस्टमर्स
के लिए पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग करते हो तो
वहां पर सबसे पहले आप रूल्स ऑफ एंगेजमेंट
प एग्रीमेंट करते हो रूल्स ऑफ एंगेजमेंट
का मतलब क्या है कि मैं एक पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टर हूं और एक आपका क्लाइंट है तो उनके
बीच में मैं आपको बताता हूं एक मिनट जस्ट
आई राइट डाउन सम यर
कि मतलब मैं एक पेंटेस्टर्स हूं और एक
क्लाइंट है हम दोनों के बीच में एक
एग्रीमेंट होगा कि मैं सिस्टम के साथ
क्या-क्या एक्सप्लोइट कर सकता हूं कौन-कौन
से सिस्टम एक्सप्लोइट कर सकता हूं या
कौन-कौन सी टेक्निक में रन कर सकता हूं
डोस यूज कर सकता हूं नहीं कर सकता सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग यूज कर सकता हूं नहीं कर सकता
या कौन-कौन से टूल्स में यूज कर सकता हूं
नहीं कर सकता यह भी कई बार एग्रीमेंट होता
है उसके बाद क्या अगर मैं सिस्टम में
एक्सेस गेन कर लेता हूं उसके बाद क्या कर
सकता हूं क्या मैं इवेंट लॉक को डिलीट कर
सकता हूं लॉक फाइल को डिलीट कर सकता हूं
या नहीं कर सकता क्या मैं कोई यूजर क्रिएट
कर सकता हूं या नहीं कर सकता क्या कस्टमर
के डाटा के साथ मैं इंटरेक्ट कर सकता हूं
या नहीं कर सकता क्या कोई भी कॉन्फिन फाइल
ऐड कर सकता हूं या नहीं कर सकता ये सारी
चीजें आप क्या होती है आपकी रूल्स ऑफ
एंगेजमेंट के अंदर आती हैं जब भी आप क्या
करते हो बिफोर पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग आप
क्या करते हो किसी भी क्लाइंट और कस्टमर
के साथ या किसी भी कंपनी में एज ए
पेंटेस्ट जॉब करते हो तो आप रूल्स ऑफ
इंगेजमेंट साइन करते हो और आपका जब भी आप
पोस्ट एक्सशन टेक्निक का यूज करोगे तो
आपको हमेशा रूल्स ऑफ इंगेजमेंट को ध्यान
में रखते हुए पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन टेक्निक
का यूज करना होगा अगर आपके रूल्स ऑफ
एंगेजमेंट में बोला है कि जस्ट आपको
एक्सप्लोइट करना है उसके बाद फर्द किसी
सिस्टम को एक्सप्लोइट नहीं करना या आपको
जस्ट इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करनी है कस्टमर
डाटा के साथ एक्सेस इंटरेक्शन नहीं करना
है कोई फाइल मॉडिफाई नहीं करनी है डोस
अटैक परफॉर्म नहीं करना है सोशल इंजीन
परफॉर्म नहीं करनी है और आपको और भी बहुत
सारी क्राइटेरिया अगर उसमें लिखा है तो
आपको वो परफॉर्म नहीं करनी है ओके सो
पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन फेज इज अ वेरी वेरी
इंपोर्टेंट फेज ऑफ पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग
लाइफ साइज स्किल बिकॉज एक्चुअली यू हैव
एक्सेस टू द टारगेट सिस्टम और सम ऑफ द
टेक्निक्स दैट यू विल बी रनिंग कुड
नेगेटिव इंपैक्ट द कंपनी बेसिकली कहने का
मतलब यह क्या है क्योंकि आपका आपके पास
टारगेट का एक्सेस है अब कुछ ऐसी टेक्निक्स
होती हैं जो किसी भी कंपनी को नेगेटिव
इंपैक्ट पहुंचा सकती हैं तो हमेशा आपको
पोस्ट एक्सप्लोरेशन फेज में हमेशा एक्टिव
रहना है क्या कर रहे हो क्या नहीं कर रहे
हर चीज आपको ट्रैक रिकॉर्ड में रखनी है सो
दैट एक तो कारण ये है कि आप एक्टिव रहोगे
रूल्स ऑफ एंगेजमेंट नहीं तोड़ोगे कंपनी को
लॉस नहीं करोगे दूसरा मेजर फैक्टर है कि
आपको मैं अभी इस पोस्ट एक्सप्लो फेज में
क्या-क्या कर रहा हूं कहां पर कॉन्फिन को
चेंज कर रहा हूं किस नाम से सेव कर रहा
हूं कौन सा यूजर क्रिएट कर रहा हूं यह
आपको हेल्प करती है जब आप ट्रैक कवर करते
हो जब आप व सार टेंपररी फाइल डिलीट करते
हो सिस्टम अपने सबूत मिटाते हो उस केस में
भी यह चीजें आपको ध्यान में रखनी होती है
इसलिए आंखें खुली रखनी है कि मैं अभी
सिस्टम के साथ क्या कर रहा हूं
नाउ व्हेन रनिंग पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन
टेक्निक यू नीड टू बी शोर दैट यू हैव द
नेसेसरी परमिश एंड राइट्स टू मॉडिफाई
सर्विसेस सिस्टम कॉन्फिन परफॉर्म
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन डिलीट लॉग्स एक्सट्रा
यह सारी परमिश आपके पास हो चाहिए मींस
रूल्स ऑफ एंगेजमेंट आपका बिल्कुल जो
एग्रीमेंट है बिल्कुल क्लियर होना चाहिए
कस्टमर्स और आपके बीच में ओके और रूल्स
एंगेजमेंट को आपको ब्रेक नहीं करना है ओके
तो सबको पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन का समझ में
आया मतलब कि पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन होता
क्या
है और पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन के दौरान हमें
किन-किन चीजों का ध्यान रखना है एवरीवन गट
क्लियर
एवरीवन गट
क्लियर सभी बताइए
मुझे ओके वेरी गुड
नाउ अभी पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन की कुछ मेथड
है होती है कुछ स्टेज होती हैं जो आपको
हमेशा पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन के दौरान ध्यान
में रखनी है इन ऑर्डर टू परफॉर्म कंप्लीट
पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन फेज वी नीड टू
यूटिलाइज स्ट्रक्चर्ड मेथोड दैट इनकंपास द
मोस्ट इंपोर्टेंट स्टेजेस ऑफ पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन दैट कैन बी अप्लाइड
ड्यूरिंग एंगेजमेंट ओके दिस स्ट्रक्चर्ड
एंड मेथ लॉजिकल अप्रोच इंश्योर दैट वी डू
नॉट स्किप ओवर लुक इंपोर्टेंट फेजस ऑफ
पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन फेजस
बेसिकली हर एक पन टेस्टर के द्वारा या
मोस्टली पेन टेस्टर के द्वारा इन
मेथोडोलोग्य
एक एक स्ट्रक्चर्ड वे में है सो दैट कि एक
बोलते हैं कि सर मेरे पास चेक ऑप लिस्ट
होनी चाहिए कि मुझे अभी क्या करना है क्या
नहीं करना ये वही चेक ऑफ लिस्ट है जो आपके
पास होनी चाहिए जो आपको पता होनी चाहिए कि
अगर मैंने सिस्टम में एक बार एक्सेस ले
लिया और उसके बाद मुझे क्या करना है पोस्ट
एक्सप्रेस में परफॉर्म करना है तो मुझे यह
सारी स्टेजेस हैं जो मैं परफॉर्म कर सकता
हूं तो कौन सी स्टेज मुझे अभी परफॉर्म
करनी है कौन सी स्टेज मुझे अभी परफॉर्म
नहीं करनी है तो ये सारी चीजें एक
स्ट्रक्चर्ड वे में मैं आपको बताने वाला
हूं कि कौन-कौन सी मेथड या स्टेजेज होती
हैं जो हर एक पेंटेस्टर के द्वारा फॉलो की
जाती है जिसने भी इसको बनाया द इज अ वेरी
वेरी वेरी गुड वेरी वेरी हेल्पफुल एंड
थैंक्स टू हिम कि जिसने भी इसको डिजाइन
किया है नाउ यह आपकी आठ
मेथोडोलोग्य मेशन सबसे पहले जब भी आप क्या
करते हो एक्सेस गेन कर लेते हो देन उसके
बाद क्या करते हो लोकल एन्यूमरेशन देन
ट्रांसफरिंग फाइल्स अपग्रेडिंग सेल्स
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन परसिस्टेंस नंबर
सिक्स डंपिंग एंड क्रैकिंग हैसे पिटिंग
क्लिंग योर टैक्स यह सारी की सारी आठों की
आठो आपकी क्या है पोस्ट एक्स टेशन स्टेजेज
होती हैं लोकल एन्यूमरेशन में आप क्या
करते हो एनमने इि एज मच इंफॉर्मेशन एज
पॉसिबल फ्रॉम द टारगेट सिस्टम दैट यू जस्ट
कॉम्प्रोमाइज्ड ओके अब लोकल एन्यूमरेशन
में आप क्या करते हो सीधा नमरे परफॉर्म
करना है यहां पर ज्यादा से ज्यादा उस
टारगेट के बारे में इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
करना चाहे वो उसके यूजर्स नेम हो चाहे
उसके वो ग्रुप्स के नाम हो चाहे उसके
नेटवर्क के इंफॉर्मेशन हो चाहे उसके वर्जन
की इंफॉर्मेशन हो चाहे वो सर्विसेस की
इंफॉर्मेशन हो चाहे वो मैनुअल तरीका हो
चाहे वो ऑटोमेटिक तरीका हो दो किसी भी
तरीके से आपको क्या करना है ज्यादा से
ज्यादा उस टारगेट के बारे में इंफॉर्मेशन
फाइंड आउट करनी है पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन के
लोकल एमेशन फेज के दौरान स्टेज के दौरान
सेकंड ट्रांसफरिंग फाइल्स और अपग्रेडिंग
सेल्स ये आपके ऑप्शनल होते हैं ये आपके
आपके चैलेंज के ऊपर डिपेंड करते हैं आप
किस सिचुएशन में हो आपकी सिचुएशन क्या है
क्या आपको इनकी रिक्वायरमेंट है भी या
नहीं यह तभी आपके काम में आते हैं
ट्रांसफरिंग फाइल की बात करते हैं डू यू
नीड टू ट्रांसफर एनी फाइल्स टू द टारगेट
सिस्टम आफ्टर यू हैव गेन एक्सेस क्या मुझे
एक्सेस लेने के बाद सिस्टम पर कोई फाइल
ट्रांसफर करने की जरूरत है कोई बैक डोर
कोई रिवर्स सेल या कोई ऐसा टूल्स जो मेरे
काम को ऑटोमेटिक परफॉर्म करें ये अगर आपको
जरूरत है आपको खुद के पेलोड परफॉर्म करने
की जरूरत है तो उस केस में आपको
ट्रांसफरिंग फाइल्स का जो सेकंड स्टेज है
उसको यूज करना होगा अदर वाइज अगर आपको
एक्सेस लेने के बावजूद किसी भी फाइल को
ट्रांसफर करने
रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है तो आपको इसको स्किप
भी कर सकते हो थर्ड आपका आता अपग्रेडिंग
सेल्स डू वी नीड टू अपग्रेड अवर सेल फ्रॉम
नॉन इंटरेक्ट टू इंटरेक्ट सेल कहने का
मतलब क्या है कई बार आपको ऐसा सेल का
एक्सेस मिलता है जहां पर वो इंटरेक्ट इव
नहीं है आपने कभी कभी कभी देखा होगा मैट
पलो के अंदर कि ओके वी आर गेटिंग द सेल बट
वहां पर कोई भी रूट यूजर नेम कुछ नहीं आ
जस्ट एक ब्लैंक ब्लैक स्क्रीन आ रही है
क्योंकि एक्सेस आपको मिल
सेल आपको मिल गया लेकिन वो इंटरेक्ट नहीं
है तो इंटरेक्ट में अपग्रेड करने के लिए
भी कुछ तरीके होते हैं अगर वह आपको जरूरत
है अगर आपको इंटरेक्ट सेल गेट इन करना है
तो उस केस में आप क्या कर सकते हो थर्ड
स्टेप को फॉलो कर सकते हो देन फोर्थ स्टेप
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन होता है इफ यू हैव
ऑब्टेन एक्सेस टू अ टारगेट सिस्टम विदाउट
एलिवेटेड प्रिजेस देन वी नीड टू एलीवेट
योर पजेस अगर आपको को अपने कंप्रोमाइज
सिस्टम पर अनप्रिविलेज्ड एक्सेस मिला है
और आपको हायर प्रिविलेज एक्से एक्सेस में
उसको कन्वर्ट करना है तब आप इस टस्ट को
परफॉर्म कर सकते हो अगर आपको एडमिन एक्सेस
मिला है तो उस केस में आप क्या है
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन आपको परफॉर्म करने की
जरूरत नहीं है देन फाइव मोस्ट इंपॉर्टेंट
स्टेज होती है जो हर केस में आपको परफॉर्म
करनी ही करनी पड़ती है अगर आप पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन मेथोड का यूज करते हो आपका
रूल्स ऑफ इजमेंट क्लियर है तो
वी नीड टू सेट अप ए परसिस्टेंट एक्सेस टू
योर टारगेट सिस्टम इन द इवेंट इफ द सिस्टम
इज शट डाउन और रि स्टार्टेड यू कैन गेन
एक्सेस टू द टारगेट सिस्टम विदाउट
एक्सप्लोइटिंग द वलने बिलिटी फॉर एग्जांपल
आपने इनिशियल गेन एक्सेस किया किसी भी
वनबिल के थ्रू और उस आपका क्या है कि तो
वनटी पैच कर दी गई उसी टाइम थोड़े टाइम के
बाद पता चल गया आपके कंपनी को या सामने
वाला जो सिस्टम जो आपने कंप्रोमाइज किया
था वो शट डाउन हो गया बंद हो गया या
रीस्टार्ट कर दिया कंपनी ने तो उस केस में
क्या होगा आपका जो एक्सेस है वह बंद हो
जाएगा तो उस चीज से बचने के लिए हम क्या
करते हैं अपने एक्सेस को सबसे पहले एक्सेस
गेन करने के बाद जो भी परफॉर्म करना
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन करना जो भी करना है
वह सारे परफॉर्म करने के बाद हम क्या करते
हैं फिफ स्टेस में परसिस्टेंट एक्सेस
मेंटेन करते हैं क्यों क्योंकि अगर आपका
सिस्टम शट डाउन भी हो जाएगा रीस्टार्ट भी
हो जाएगा तब भी आपका एक्सेस उस सिस्टम में
रहेगा आप डायरेक्टली जब भी व सिस्टम ऑन
होगा या जब भी रि स्टार्ट होगा आपको उस
वलन बिलिटी के थ्रू उसको एक्सेस लेने की
जरूरत नहीं होगी डायरेक्टली उसका एक्सेस
ऑटोमेटिक आपके बैक डोर के द्वारा आपको मिल
जाएगा तो दिस इज द मोस्ट इंपोर्टेंट स्टेप
ऑफ पर्सिस सिक्स स्टेज आती है आपकी डंपिंग
एंड क्रैकिंग हैसे वी कैन यूटिलाइज दज सस
फॉर लेजिटीमेट लेजिटीमेट ऑथेंटिकेशन उसके
बाद हम क्या करते हैं कि जो भी हैश होते
हैं चाहे व एल एम हैश हो चाहे वो आपके सा
512 हैश हो उनको हम डंप करते हैं डंप करके
उसके बाद उन पर ब्रूट फोर्स ट्राई करते
हैं ब्रूट फोर्स ट्राई करके हम उनको क्या
करते हैं क्रैक करने की कोशिश करते हैं और
क्रैक करने के बाद हम उस सिस्टम में एज ए
लेजिटीमेट एक वैलिड यूजर के रूप में उसको
क्या करते हैं हम उसमें एंटर करते हैं
सेवन स्टेप जो हमारा होता है वो होता है
हमारा पिवेट पिवेट क्या होता है
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
को आपने कंप्रोमाइज किया है उसके अंदर और
भी सिस्टम्स को
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
अवेलेबल हैं तब हम पिवेट करते हैं उस
कंप्रोमाइज सिस्टम के थ्रू हम उस नेटवर्क
को स्कैन करते हैं इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
करते हैं पोर्ट फॉरवर्डिंग करते हैं अपने
टूल्स रन करते हैं फिर उसके साथ हम क्या
करते हैं अपना सेशन मैनेज करते हैं एक्सेस
करते हैं अगेन एक्सेस करते हैं एक्सप्लोइट
करते हैं तो ये सारा पार्ट क्या होता है
आपका पिवेट में रहता है देन एट एंड लास्ट
स्टेप जो होता है आपका जब आपने कंप्लीट
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग कर ली देन सबसे लास्ट
आपका जो स्टेप रहता है कि अब इस इसके बाद
आपको टारगेट सिस्टम के साथ कुछ भी नहीं
करना है आपको जैसा के जैसी मशीन मिली थी
जैसा जैसा एनवायरमेंट मिला था आपने जो कुछ
परफॉर्म कर लिया उसको एटीज प्रोवाइड करना
है उस केस में आप क्या करते हो अपने वो
सारे ट्रैक्स रिकॉर्ड क्लियर करना चाहते
हो उस केस में आप क्या करते
हो क्लियर ट्रैक्स वाली जो अप्रोच है उसको
यूज करते हो वो सारे सबूत मिटा देते हो उस
मशीन से जिसके थ्रू आपने एंटर किया था तो
दीज आर द एट स्टेजेस जो आप पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन फेज के दौरान यूज करते हो
नंबर वन लोकल एन्यूमरेशन ट्रांसफरिंग
फाइल्स अपग्रेडिंग सेल्स प्र एस्केलेशंस
परसिस्टेंस डंपिंग क्रैकिंग हैसे पिवेट और
क्लीयरिंग टैक्स यह सारी इंडिपेंडेंट है
अगर आपने किसी एक टारगेट पर सारे परफॉर्म
कर लिए उसके बाद आपको पता चला कि इस
नेटवर्क के अंदर और भी कोई टारगेट है आप
उस परे क्या कर दो हो पिवेट किया मूव करके
उसपे मूव करने के बावजूद क्योंकि आपके पास
उसका एक्सेस है फिर भी आप उस परे क्या
करोगे फिर अगर पोस्ट एक्सप्लो में परफॉर्म
करोगे तो ये सारी स्टेज वन टू एट फिर से
आप उसपे ट्राई कर सकते हो मतलब क्या ये
कंटीन्यू एक साइकिल में चलती है फिक्स
नहीं है कि एक ही बार परफॉर्म कर सकते हो
आप फिर से उसपे 1 2 3 4 5 एज पर योर
रिक्वायरमेंट किसी को स्किप करना तो आप कर
सकते हो तो दिस इज द पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन
मेथड जो आप यूज करोगे पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन
फेज के दौरान ओके तो एवरीवन कि आपको समझ
में आ गया होगा सिस्टम और होस्ट बेस
अटैक्स क्या होते हैं एक्सप्लोइटेशन फेज
क्या होता है और एक्सप्लोइटेशन फेज में हम
क्या-क्या पढ़ने वाले हैं सिस्टम और होस्ट
बेस अटैक्स में हम क्या पढ़ने वाले हैं
पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन फेज होता क्या है और
पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन फेज की क्या-क्या
मेथड है यह सारी चीजें आपको समझ में आ गई
होगी और आज का सेशन इतना ही था थैंक यू और
किसी का कोई भी डाउट्स है तो आप मुझसे पूछ
सकते हो
य प प य स्लाइड आपको मिल जाएगी पूरी की
पूरी समप्रीत आपकी इंफॉर्मेशन जस्ट आपको
बताता हूं आई एम स्टार्टिंग फ्रॉम 2018
जस्ट आप इतना याद रखिए इससे ज्यादा नाई
जाने आपके लिए बेटर रहेगा
य शोर मुखर्जी हम ट्राई करेंगे शोक को
अफोर्डेबल बनाने के लिए
अगर आप एक नॉर्मल यूजर के रूप में किसी भी
सिस्टम पर एक्सेस लेते हो तो वह आपके
परमिशन पर डिफाइन करता है कि वहां पर क्या
परमिशन आपको क्या आप उस फाइल को कॉपी करने
के लिए या कुछ भी करने के लिए परमिश है या
नहीं है वह सारी की सारी आपकी परमिशन पर
डिफाइन करता है आपके अगर आपके पास वहां पर
परमिशन नहीं है तो आप उस सिस्टम के साथ
कुछ भी नहीं कर
सकते इंद्रजीत यह ओनली फंडामेंटल था यह
सिम हैकिंग का डे वन था यह फर्स्ट डे था
अभी सिस्टम हैकिंग नेक्स्ट वन एंड टू मंथ
के लिए चलने वाली है जिसमें दे लॉट ऑफ
लैब्स जिसमें हम कवर करेंगे विंडोज हैकिंग
प्लस में लिनक्स हैकिंग दोनों प हैक हैक
परफॉर्म करेंगे सीटीएफ के थ्रू और वहां पर
जो भी मल्टीपल टेक्निक्स आएंगी और जो जो
पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन फेजेस की मैंने बात
की जिनन जिन एक्सप्लोइटेशन फेजेस की मैंने
बात की जहां जहां पर सिस्टम होस्ट बेस
अटैक की बात की यह सारी सारी टेक्निक्स
मैं आपको प्रैक्टिकली इन सेशंस में
करवाऊंगी वन बाय वन
नहीं अभी के लिए अब्दुल थ्योरी खत्म हो गई
है लेकिन थ्योरी क्या रहेगी कि जो कुछ
फंडामेंटल टॉपिक रहेंगे बीच-बीच में जब
मैं लैब सीटीएफ के बीच में परफॉर्म
करवाऊंगी तो कुछ फंडामेंटल टॉपिक रहेंगे
जस्ट वन टू स्लाइड के उनको वहीं पर क्लियर
करेंगे हां एक थरी टिकल पार्ट बचे हुए हैं
वैसे तो क्रिप्टोग्राफी थोट कल रहेगा
फंडामेंटल्स ऑफ विंडोस भी आपका थरेट कल
रहेगा प्रैक्टिकल प्लस थरेट
कल बथ वेज दोनों तरीके आप सीख
लोगे संप्रत एआई यूज इन हैकिंग तो अभी मैं
उस पर कुछ प्लानिंग सोच रहा हूं तो जिसमें
मैं कुछ या तो एडवांस जो हैकिंग रहेगी
उसमें मैं एडवांस जो पन टेस्टिंग रहेगी
उसमें ड ऑन करूंगा माय प्लान है कि मैं
उसको पेड रखूंगा फ्री में नहीं डिलीवर कर
सकता और एआई को मैं जल्दी अपने कोर्सेस
में ऐड करने वाला
हूं जीजी पीटी का प्राइस आप डायरेक्टली
वेबसाइट पर जाक चेक कर लीजिए अराउंड
$35 या $300 कुछ है
या इंद्रजीत आपने डीई कोर्स परचेज किया यह
फ्री वाला है और आपको सर्टिफिकेट मिलेगा
और मास्टर्स के लिए आपको हम करवाएंगे अगर
आप लोग एग्री करोगे जस्ट पे
सम बेसिक अमाउंट जो आपका अफोर्डेबल रहेगा
उस केस में आप क्या कर सकते हो हमारे
एडवांस कोर्सेस भी ले सकते हो पढ़ सकते हो
नहीं संप्रत मुझे प्री रिकॉर्डेड कोर्स
में कोई इंटरेस्ट नहीं है जस्ट आई एम
इंटरेस्टेड ओनली इन लाइव
क्लासेस मुझे इंटरेक्ट करते हुए क्लासेस
लेना पसंद है और मुझे अच्छा लगता है
रिकॉर्ड करने में मैं बोर हो जाता
हूं तो किसी का क्लास रिलेटेड कोई डाउट है
य सेशन को एंड करें बताइए
बताइए बताइए बताइए बोलिए किसी का क्लास
रिलेटेड कोई डाउट है
नेटवर्किंग क्लास का अभी मुझे कोई आईडिया
नहीं
है उसके बारे में अभी मैं आपको नहीं बता
सकता
शॉर्ट टर्म में एडवांस चीजें नहीं सीखी
जाती
अखिलेश तो चलिए फिर सेशन को एंड करते हैं
और
हम नेक्स्ट सेशन में मिलते
हैं तो एक्टिव इनोवेट इसका डिफरेंस अभी आप
ही मुझे बताइए इतना तो मैं आपको पढ़ा चुका
हूं और आपको इतना तो रिसर्च खुद से करना
पड़ेगा नहीं डीसीएसपी में टॉपिक कवर नहीं
है यह एक इंटरमीडिएट कोर्स है डीसीएसपी
में एडवांस टॉपिक्स आर कवर्ड यह टॉपिक
कवर्ड नहीं है डीसीएसपी में तो एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी भी है और और भी बहुत कुछ है
हां डीप है डीसीएसपी में और बहुत सारी
चीजें जो काफी डीप है और एडवांस है बट
इसमें यह नहीं है यह जस्ट एक बेसिक टू
अफोर्डेबल कोर्स है एक प्रीमियम क्वालिटी
कोर्स है जहां पर आप पीजी पीटी कर सकते हो
क् बीजी पीटी जैसे एग्जाम्स है व ज्यादा
हार्ड नहीं
है ओके सेशन को एंड करते हैं एंड नेक्स्ट
सेशन में मिलते हैं जल्दी अपने प्रैक्टिकल
के साथ फर्स्ट ईटीएफ के साथ फर्स्ट लैब के
साथ स्टार्टिंग में हम बिल्कुल बेसिक
छोटी-छोटी लैब्स परफॉर्म करेंगे बिल्कुल
बेसिक आप सबको आती होंगी मे बी जिसमें मैं
सब कांसेप्चुअल लेकर जाऊंगा कि हर टॉपिक
को आपको कंपेयर करूंगा क्योंकि यहां पर
एक्सप्लोइटेशन फेज है यहां पर पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन फेज है और ये कौन सी वनबिल
है और धीरे-धीरे हम क्या है कि एक बिल्कुल
बिगनर को लेके एक इंटरमीडिएट मतलब कि ले
लैब सारी बेसिक ही रहेंगी बट आपको क्या है
कि वहां पर टेक्निक्स ट्रिक्स मिल जाएंगी
ओके
या नेक्स्ट क्लास में होगा अनुराग तो सेशन
को एंड करते हैं बाय बाय टेक केयर एंड गुड
नाइट एंड अगेन हैप्पी न्यू ईयर एंड एंजॉय
र नाइट बाय बाय टेक केयर एंड सी यू फॉर
नेक्स्ट सेशन बाय बाय